what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
all right before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way and as that is the
most important metric that YouTube uses
to push out these streams as you guys
already know if you have watched two or
more of my lives and you don't subscribe
we have beef okay beef people
um quick announcements before we start
the show um the first is um how many
likes to open up the chat today King
what
all right 1 500 likes and we'll open up
the chat today
um so if you guys want otherwise make
sure you sign up for our memberships and
then um second thing is how many over
what dollar super chats are we reading
today
20 bucks okay over 20 we are reading
Super Chat so if you have a question for
the panel or something you want to say
make sure
um you send a super chat so um to start
we're gonna do name age relationship
status and a fun fact about yourself
starting here go around and then second
row
hi I'm fee I'm 35 and I'm married and a
fun fact about myself is I like tasting
baby food
is it good it it well depends on what
you try to be honest with you
go ahead
um
your turn uh I'm Natalia I have a child
for years old time psychologist and the
fresh divorced you can say like this
okay go ahead
oh me hello area 36 and
divorce and a mom
okay go ahead look very rich oh the the
color is different on stream okay
because it's just the setting on the TV
go ahead
uh hi my name is Shima I'm a mother of
I'm I'm a wonderful son a wonderful boy
and
do I need to say my age yeah oh 40 plus
all right thank you
hi my name is Nima and uh I have a
daughter
and wife
and one fun thing about me is uh
I like to box
that's cool
hi my name is Rana I'm 35 years of age I
have a daughter and I'm married fun
facts about me is I love to sing
what kind of music
all types r b gospel afrobe
go ahead hi my name is nura I'm 40 years
old and um I have two children and I'm
an esthetician
okay
hello I'm maliha and
um
uh sorry I'm 43 years old I'm a single
mom of two kids and one fun fact about
me I love jumping on trampoline
ever jumped on a rectangle one oh not
the rectangle one but mini trampoline
yeah if you get the rectangle ones
they're so much more bouncy oh it's like
it's like you go so much you go so much
higher it's crazy that's it great
um okay so today
um we are going to talk about being
married versus being single um for a
lifetime
so my first question is do you think
that women
can be happy for a lifetime single no
starting here and then go around but we
can I'll go ahead go ahead
um to be honest I think it depends on
how you
have a relationship whilst you're single
are you single while stating are you
single and still see seeking a
companionship or are you just solely by
yourself and I feel like if you're
solely by yourself I don't think you can
actually 100 be happy on your own
um I don't think you have to be married
to be happy in particular but I do feel
like you would need some kind of
companionship whether that's a long
lasting one or one that lasts two or
three years but I feel like everyone
seeks to have that kind of someone that
they can share part of their life with
okay yeah
I think the main mission of women to be
in love and when you're not in love you
will never happy you can have career you
can be in Forbes you can have millions
but when you're not in love you have one
Gap inside you and you feel very looking
for this because we're born to be in
love it's our main mission even not to
be a mother to be in love
okay
um yeah sort of echo what everyone is
saying so I feel
that being no one wants to be lonely
really I don't think anyone wants to be
lonely
um and I think even if you have
everything in life materialistic ways
you want to share it with someone
whether it's family a companion so yeah
whether it's a husband or your life
partner definitely something that adds
value to life because we want we want to
share our happiness so um yeah
I agree
um for me
there is Millions answer for this
question because
there is a million factors that indicate
and bring happiness and
um Define and has a different definition
for being single but if the single
um your question means not being in a
relationship with someone and which sort
of relationship Mario is being important
so yeah so when I say single I say not
in a long-term relationship or married I
know some people do like the seven eight
year relationships I think that's a
little different but single for a
lifetime or constantly between
relationships why not of course there is
no rules that anyone must marry to be
happy I think there's no fixed rule many
people are single and happy and many
people are not single and
um you know and are in a relationship
unhappy so for me why not of course okay
I I yeah I think it's possible but very
unlikely
yeah like I don't I don't think women in
general and I think you could see that
because women get on antidepressants
when we're old and single over the age
of 45 that's like the most women you see
on antidepressants but uh for me as a
healthcare professional I met many
people many patients
um many clients that are single and
um they're happy but what is the
definition of happy you know is is uh is
very vague that's a very good point yeah
defined as how if a scale of one to ten
how much you're happy you know if you
say happy it's just very very cool yeah
I think women can be happy single till
their looks fade I think that's
typically when the happiness goes my
opinion
question for the for the women right no
what do you think
it's a question for you I mean you're
you're 40 40 42. okay and you've seen
women that stayed single right yeah so
what's your opinion do you think women
can stay single and happy for a lifetime
I would say for a man or a woman uh uh I
mean happiness comes from within but
I think it is I think when you get older
you start seeing your parents pass away
your grandparents pass away and you get
lonely
what happens when you get sick I know
when I got sick
my wife helped me I was bleeding sick
you know she helped me she helped me
when I couldn't stand up
and when I got out the hospital my
daughter was there and my wife was there
I couldn't imagine
someone going through something where
they get sick and they don't have a wife
and daughter
so I would say you might feel happy when
you're single and alone
but what are you going to do when your
wife you know your boys your girls they
got married they get married they get
family and they got kids and you know
they move on once once your friends
start getting married and having kids
you're going to start seeing a little
bit of distance I think and that's
natural yeah
uh literally following on from what um
this gentleman saying I agree
um and taking points of what everyone
has said it's like what is happiness
first and foremost and yes we're you
know Center in this conversation around
women but I think it applies equally to
men a man and you were saying as their
looks Fades Beauty
it doesn't mean one thing for women and
one thing for men we're all physical
beings our Beauty and our looks fade
over time equally so no they do not
women's books fade much quicker
unnecessarily but if you look at even if
they've done studies on facial
elasticity so it's how much men's like
like the wrinkles in your skin come
women versus men women wrinkle faster
okay fair point however I stand on the
plane that I'm saying that you know
taking away the point you're making
about beauty
even if you're not married and you
choose to be a single person in terms of
when you tick the Box you are single
even if you take the books in your
cohabiting or you know you have a
partner right I think there's a longing
within everybody everybody wants to know
that they are cared for by somebody that
they are loved by somebody that somebody
is going to take care of them in their
time of need so
I don't think it applies to him I think
men as well even if men are alone you
can you can earn all the money that you
want you can buy all the big houses but
you're going to buy a big house and
living alone is that going to make you
happy you can buy the big fast cars and
drive them alone because I've thought
about this right and and I kind of go I
go both sides because sometimes I think
of Hugh Hefner was that man unhappy
I've seen I've seen Hugh Hefner on a
Wednesday night at Concord no way yeah a
nightclub in Hollywood around 2004 and I
remember seeing Hugh Hefner but like on
a Tuesday night like five women
I don't know if he was deep down happy
or not but he seemed like he was having
a good time yeah but I don't know well
because it's like we have this idea
about like men are if they don't get
married and have kids they'll be lonely
too and I just don't see it the same for
men and for women I think women get much
more lonely the older they get
um I don't think so because I feel like
men when they lose their spouses they
tend to actually become more depressing
entering the depression actually women
losing their spouses so and even when it
comes to family yeah I don't think
that's the same though because that's
like the loss of a partner that's not
never getting a partner Oh by oh so your
question is if a woman never gets a
point yeah if she ends up single oh okay
I think my point is it depends on the
community she has and the other
relationships she has I get it um there
is this thing about but there are so
many women who are married and not happy
as well right like you know so when we
say about single women being happy my
question then arises is
have you got those relationships like
I'm from a very big family and I I tell
you from friends to my neighbors to
everybody like right now I'm single I've
been married for 18 years I am much
happier right now that I've ever been
and if you ask me would I rather be with
the person
with him I'm miserable or not because
you know
um it's also about compatibility and
stuff like that but as a single woman
right now I think that's about
compatibility uh we with the men as well
because obviously a man or the other
person can't make keep you happy all the
time either so when we are talking about
our happiness then it comes from within
so if it comes from within yeah that's
what I was yeah you I think the only
thing I would say then the order is okay
that physical connection with somebody
you can hug and says this is the person
is mine but anything else you know if
you want to go for a cup of coffee a man
probably doesn't might not want to do it
at that time even so you're gonna go
ahead so I was just saying you can go by
yourself and have that coffee do you
translate that as single yourself
although you're still in the
relationship with someone so my point is
a woman can stay single and happy it's
just um how you're interpreting it in
the sense of
um
like a woman cannot stay single if she
has really good relationships around her
her girlfriends could be her closest
friends like one of my single friends
say if I don't find the right guy I'll
just when I'm old and I'm fragile I'll
get all my single girlfriends and we
live in the same house and we live
happily together like you know because
at that time you need help have you ever
seen sorority houses they all fight like
men exactly but I'm just saying who is
it is it because because the man is not
there but yeah I I think it is I can't
even imagine like life at six like what
does life at 60 look like without a man
um
basically I disagree with this statement
that man brings happiness it's a very
old and classic statement and phrases
that they said happiness should come
through everything of you may I and
and I should come you have to be happy
you find happiness definition of
happiness in your life and if there is a
gentleman wants to come to your life
they will add something to that not
because they bring the happiness they
will add something well my my point is I
don't think women typically are happy
over a certain age with no no man or
kids I think women get happiness from
relationships and when women don't have
relationships I just don't I don't think
people are in a relationship and on
unhappy it's I don't I don't see any you
know scientific logic behind this
sentence that we need a man a certain
age well I'll say like what I would say
what I would say to indicate that is
that women aren't antidepressants at a
higher rate when they don't get married
and they don't have children like that
is the single most like most this is
medicated this is what they choose you
know this is why they select they want
to be why should everyone be a mother
why should everyone yeah I'm not I'm not
saying every person has to be a mother
but the majority of women wanted kids
so the majority of women that don't have
kids like initially wanted kids
um I
you know in science or in my part you
have to bring the numbers and you have
to bring them you know you have to bring
some a very strong logic then you said
majority of them and where well they
serve it they serve it they surveyed a
couple thousand women I can't remember
the exact institution but it was a
college in the U.S they surveyed I think
three thousand to five thousand women
asking if they wanted that were single
and did not have kids asking if they
wanted kids and I want to say it was 80
85 I can't off the top of my head 85 so
many countries uh the rate of you know
are having the child is goes negative
you know you're right you're right so
they are not happy they are happy I do I
do think I do think it has short-term
happiness I absolutely do I think
there's what does it mean short-term
happiness that means they're happy now
but they're not happy in the long term
because because life life looks really
different at at 60 than it does at 25 at
35 I actually think that most women
don't really know what happy is but I
actually read a statistic that showed
that women are the happiest
when they're given a [__]
[Laughter]
oh good come here go ahead go ahead yeah
go ahead so uh predominantly I think we
have middle-aged women here
um all may be married divorced
we're in that situation where I think
most of us all
um divorced at the moment and I think
we're kidding ourselves when we're
saying we're going to be happy without a
man and that we don't need to get
married we need a man and we're just no
one is saying that here but what was the
question the question was yesterday
can women be happy for a lifetime no
they cannot they cannot so if any like
most I think have said yes they can no
they cannot because when they're single
they're still looking they're on dating
websites and you know you're like you
said you were 43 and you're happy and
you're single and you're in the because
you're beautiful you're still beautiful
but you will Aid you will get older
comes health and you know you will need
a partner
but who guaranteed it that partner will
be there when I needed him
um uh you know in terms of that
happiness because I feel like one man
cannot provide you with everything if
you have a community of people if you
have lots of amazing relationships
commitment commitment I'm not I'm not
saying
um I'm uh see there are other needs that
a man can fulfill for a woman yes they
are there but happiness is not the
grounding for oh I need to have a man uh
for because he's going to make me happy
you have to make yourself happy you have
to learn make yourself happy yeah but
there are other needs obviously God made
a man because you cannot fulfill that
Gap see that's what I believe I believe
you will need a man eventually I I
personally think that my personal
experience after being in a marriage for
18 years I always see men as like a
security for me coming from a Asian
background it's always just like he's my
he's my back like so other men can't
approach me I feel safe I feel protected
that's something I can say yes a man can
provide for life and when I become
single I'm exposed to all these men's
because I'm single now so I'm single
moment I've learned from men to approach
me and I've done so much self-work and
growth if a man approaches me like no
I'm not available I'm in a relationship
it's you you need to work on your
self-love and you need to your
self-control so if somebody comes to you
and wants you no I'm in a relationship
absolutely you can say that but what I'm
saying is once you are married you just
have that okay that's my protection
there that's my security maybe it's the
way I've been raised as well like you
know so for me that urge of okay having
that protection or leaning on someone
when you're finding like as a single mom
challenges around kids and stuff who can
I lean on uh or so it's interesting I
just you know I wonder because like then
who if you don't get married who takes
care of you
you can take care of yourself we are
mature people why we are I don't know
what I'm saying at some point you're
gonna have health everyone does I cannot
just say something like we don't need
this there's a difference between a
woman choosing to be single because I
feel that it's always a choice for women
it is always a choice it's a choice
not one out of three men are sexless
it's not a choice but yes it's not like
there's a whole group of men that have
no choice because no women want them
most men didn't even reproduce
historically only 40 of men reproduced
how does that take away from them
because because again because women what
all right now in modern times what what
starts relationships sex right women are
in control of sex there's always someone
willing to sleep with a woman there's
always someone willing to date a woman
that is true always there's not always
someone willing to date a man
right that may be so so therefore women
always have Choice men do not okay let
me tell you why that is true and also
not true okay because in the beginning
yes you're right a woman does to have
control of the sex part in terms of like
introducing sex but once the sex
relationship is established the power
dynamics completely changed you're right
you're right you're right but my point
is where does it start and you you maybe
you some you guys are a bit older but in
modern times in modern times and most
relationships start with sex no if you
uh yes
dating apps are the number one people
way people are meeting under the age of
30. yeah come on you you know we can't
speak to a personal experience right
experience because we have to speak
right right let's begin from a general
experience yeah yeah so like I
understand that but we can't ignore the
fact that that the power dynamics do
change with men in terms of they take
leadership of where the relationship
will go most women actually wait on a
man to be to define the relationship
whether where we are where are we we're
women but we pick the type of men we
date right so you say you either pick a
marriage mind a guy or you don't it's
true that's true as well that's very
true but one saying in terms of like
wait until you're 60 ukip for example I
was I was in a relationship for 13 years
was married
um I got married quite young well some
will say I'm young 24 years old
um and then in my late 20s it was my
first partner from the time I was 16
years old so I start actually dating the
you know the age of 28. right and I'm in
my mid-30s now
um
I've only been let's say single roughly
around six years so now I'm now looking
for a relationship because I love love I
want to be in a relationship I want to
be married again I love companionship I
believe in ID I believe in the idea
um but I can find a partner and we may
be married for like 20 years so let's
say 45 55 I'm not saying I'm not putting
that into the atmosphere I hope that is
for life but let's say we may be married
for 20 years and anything can happen it
might be a loss people lose you know I
lost my close friend my best friend in
January and her partner now is a weirdo
for example and he's only in his they're
both in the mid-30s so anything can
happen it could be life we we're not the
same people as we are 10 years ago one
of the reasons I don't think that
matters though I don't think it matters
because you know why because I say oh
100 emails I'm gonna go to that point
but what I'm trying to say is so now 50
you're 55 for whatever reason now the
separation you know is is done I don't
think that you take away your experience
that you've had for the past 20 years so
you've had a good 20 years of experience
just like many people like our
grandparents a lot of them lose their
Partners but they still are you know
yeah they become lonely but sometimes
it's not all about choices sometimes
things in life happens as humans we're
human individually no but I would say
the majority of single women it's a
choice I mean I mean we could we could
talk about being a widow that's an
exception but the rules it's a choice
women leave relationships men don't I do
after there's context behind that no one
leaves I think women will always make up
a reason there's always some reason like
grow apart marriage isn't about growing
apart it's not about liking your partner
it's about Duty a hundred percent so
when the juice exactly so both men so I
have a role in my marriage and the man
has a role in his marriage so what if
the man is not fulfilling those those
marriages and remember but then it's
like it's so hypocritical because it's
like well women are supposed to be
virgins on their wedding night most
women are virgins on their wedding night
so we're not perfect either but yeah we
expect Perfection from our husbands no
that's not Perfection no one's expecting
Perfection I literally just asked there
are duties I'm not perfect either is he
no one's talking about Perfections here
we're talking about standard
expectations within a marriage so if
that man for example because
um you you said people change people I
mean the matter of changing doesn't
um exist for someone I've got to know it
doesn't exist why it doesn't I said I I
think I imply it was a silly reason for
divorce the reason why I say that for
example I met my partner 16 years old
right in college yes right when you meet
someone at 16 we're both kids what
you're looking for a partner in your
when you're 16 it's completely different
when you become an adult you know who
now knows in a way what they want
because they become they come into their
own adulthood you know who they are as a
person so in that time as we're growing
up as when we became adults we got to a
point where we both knew in a way
because you I think someone mentioned
about compatibility right
there is more to marriage and
relationships than love there's other
things that constitutes marriage we both
didn't understand what constitute
imagined me because of our age at the
time uh we didn't have that we weren't
equipped with the right mindset when we
got into the situation because it's not
just oh I love you let's get married so
what is what does that mean though I
need a specific so what I'm saying to
you is if you if two people that are not
compatible end up in the marriage there
are things that are going to happen
eventually that's going to bring up
issues over resentment towards each
other because one person is expecting
that person to mirror the other person
that's going and that goes vice versa
between men can I have a specific
example of what this means because it's
just this is very broad so I need
anything okay so for example
a man for example you're in a
relationship
and let's say you start earning more
than your partner because we're going
signing with a new partner
um you both grow halves on each other
but for some reason that man okay feels
less than a man because he's earning
less than you okay this is not nothing
really that I can actually do because
that's an individual thing for a person
I would ask why he feels that way
because a lot of times what women do is
they throw it in the guy's face and they
constantly bring it a lot of women do a
lot of them
I'm not talking about you it's wrong and
it's unfair and yeah but I'm not I'm not
talking about it a lot of women do but I
think sometimes as well we have to be
very balanced in terms of sometimes we
push this narrative that women they are
stopped there's 100 toxic women that
you're speaking of but we're not talking
in this context so there are there are
sometimes that men within themselves
feel that they haven't found themselves
which is in a way in our 20s we're still
finding ourselves and then they may feel
inferior because they might be earning
less and I've never heard a guy talk
about finding himself that's like oh my
god
I've heard guys talk about maturing but
I I've but that's
us
typically when men talk about finding
themselves is because they've had it a
lot from women and they know that that
is a language that works for women most
of the time they're just lying to you
because they want to get something from
you can I can I suggest I'm sorry when
you're talking about um they've heard it
from women sometimes it's not it could
be a very it could be a various
circumstances that come about that a man
has to find himself it could be yes he's
come out of a relationship it could be
he's trying to find the right career it
could be it could be it could be a
religious from a religious perspective
he needs to look within himself to to
you know become this greater being it's
not just and we're putting a lot of
things always the woman it's the women
and not women
the reason we say it's the woman because
the data indicates that it is
so so the data the data talks about who
files for a divorce you can just
listening
what do you mean there's no contact what
I'm saying to you is you said statistics
the ticks might be found in the western
world because that's what the stigma
okay
but there is no context as to the
reasons why because I'll tell you
something why why I'm saying this a
woman would stick more in a relationship
a toxic relationship an abusive
relationship for many many many many
many many more years than a man would
women pick toxic relationships
how do you get into a relationship with
someone if you don't pick them because
people change
it
this is an excuse
use this is an excuse that women use to
justify picking poorly
ninety percent of the time when women
are in toxic relationships because they
didn't get their father's advice their
brother's advice or their friends advice
half the time their everybody is warning
them telling them not to date them and
they do anything you almost 10 years ago
you am I the same person I would say I
have very similar traits than I did last
year
because nobody when you take vows it's
For Better or For Worse
it's not it's not it's not for when for
when we grow apart no that's not the
reason can I say something
obviously but I I think a man will leave
if he's not if it's not 100 there and he
doesn't want to be with you he will
leave he would cheat he would disrespect
you yes he will not call you he would
not return those messages he's left he's
not interested you're holding on to
something you're you're almost like
begging to be with somebody you're
trying to make this work a woman will do
that but a man has already left and but
the men don't leave the majority
but the only thing when they're cheating
when they speak like something else
it's only a small percentage of men that
can cheat it's a very small percentage
of men that actually care
can I add Dynamics facts
it also takes courage and a good that
you're saying that a lot of women are
the one who leaves it takes courage to
leave a relationship no I disagree it
does no it does especially in a society
it takes courage to do the easy things
the easy thing is to leave
it
is
oh my God
have you been married this is this is
the craziest
this is the crazy things
what I want to say because you're making
it personal when it's not worse
because I asked Paul you're having a
really normal constructive conversation
with you I shared my experience of in my
marriage and I said I got with someone
when I was 16 we were both young yeah
and I think at 16 like I said your your
your views and relationship in terms of
what you want it's very different from
what you're thinking right I understand
your point of view that if a woman at a
certain age when they're adults now
should make now healthier choices and
better decisions so when they do make
those choices as adults they should make
you know healthier and better decisions
so when they are in a marriage that that
marriage actually is a healthy marriage
I understand that point of view but when
I'm giving you examples I'm saying that
there's a lot of context behind your
so-called statistics that you get from
wherever you get but when I ask you are
you married it's not a dig at you it's
because you can only speak of what like
our family knowledge and our exp our
knowledge I don't think I don't think I
don't think I don't think the person
said how to take the person
I don't think that the person saying
something matters is true Brewer is it
not true is it harder to stick something
out or to leave like you can only notice
it makes no sense
the question you want to ask if she
asked if she was married so if she if
she's been married she's been married
the thing is it's the experience so
she's married that she would understand
and I want to understand where her
perspective
you know why because women usually that
haven't been married are usually the
woman that come out women that have been
married it's usually the case so no let
me say something to do no happily
married people no ever
no my point is
my point is if you say have you been
married it makes complete sense okay can
you change your question then let me
just make my thing my point is if you
ask her have you been married and you
don't follow it up with a question I
just did it look what was the question
you didn't even answer no no
she answered everything
speak you've asked her have you been
married which isn't really necessarily
relevant in your opinion
are you gonna let me speak
you've asked her have you been married
which is not necessarily relevant to
what we're talking about because
letting me speak my point is we were yes
the general topic is about marriage but
we were on a particular trajectory do
within the discussion and then you
brought up have you been married to this
to derail that conversation because if
you're asking if she's been married what
is the relevance of that to what we're
talking about in this very second so you
you'd have to ask that then follow it up
with a relevant question or then it's a
dig
sorry go on and I say this respectfully
women are meant to be quiet docile and
submissive in almost every case when you
see a woman is the opposite of that
for example for example what's your name
in the white in the white top
if it doesn't want a woman like that
go ahead go ahead come on it's just it's
just an observation and to the earlier
point about you know the question that
you said earlier I was actually once
driving my date home and she said to me
I don't need a man
I said are you sure she said yeah I said
so get the [__] out the car and
hitchhike
turned out
she got kidnapped
and that's a great example of why women
need men
excuse me I just wants to add something
in my opinion
uh the woman coming to the relationship
with many reasons
either I'm finding it really hard to
keep a straight face I'm sorry I'm
finding this so hilarious uh either they
want to fill the Gap in their life
because they feel they are not enough at
themselves
oh I did I don't really want to add
something to their life they think I'm
good I'm in a good point I know myself I
work on myself I'm fulfilled you know I
don't need someone else to give me that
positive energy you know bring something
to me but I want I would love to someone
come to my life as a man and add
something like when the child coming at
something and the good friends come and
add something and you have a good
broader and sister they add something to
our life and the same uh the the men and
women can go out of the relationship for
many reasons it can be because they are
not compatible because there is first of
the time you know when they meet each
other with each other there's a lot of
hormone engage and when the hormones
suppress during the time they said oh
she's not thinking like me he's not
behaving the way I want you know we are
two different personality doesn't mean
if you are good or bad we are just
different or maybe things they are
cheating
um they are you know
it really should a point that you know
we don't want each other we don't like
each other anymore yeah but I yeah I
under I understand that that happens but
I just don't think it's a good reason
when you're kids
because kids are more likely to go to
prison they're more likely to drop out
of school they're more likely to be
abused because when we talk about
growing apart it's like you're gonna
divorce over growing apart when you have
a kid because it's not supposed to be
about you it's supposed to be about the
kid oh my God
if I give you my example my son is at
University at Warwick University I left
my husband I'm not I'm not talking about
you though like this is like a lot of
times people take this stuff personally
what I'm saying is
um in fact both my kids said to me and
that's a feedback given to a parent by
the children is Mom I cannot believe you
stayed in that relationship for so long
we are so happy you did that they even
tried to approach their dad and come but
what I'm saying is
um there is a perspective towards it but
can I interrupt I have to interrupt
because I have two children I've I've
seen witnessed everything I know the
world I know everyone for a child not
having a personal dig at anyone
hypothetically speaking very child I'm a
mum of two for a child to come to a
parent and say Mom I can't believe you
stayed with Dad it's like what have you
said to that child for that child to say
that to you it shouldn't it should not
have witnessed it should love his mum
and dad equally it that's what you call
narcissistic toxic abuse feeding it to
the children at its highest level it
depends what the child the children are
human beings they are observant as well
I say good I'm sorry didn't raise my
voice I have a microphone but as a good
mother you tell that child it's your
father have a good relation healthy
even if it's toxic even if it's shots I
haven't finished my point let me finish
my point I tell my children whenever
your father is ready go and meet him
it's not possible I was hiding that
surprise because I know but what you are
trying to say is I have always put
positive projection towards your dad I
said he give you birth he has done this
job after that there is no response
possibility of him do you know what do
you what do you mean that's not positive
projection that he no I mean like
positive projection of this he's an
honorable man he's a good man
he gave birth to you no no I mean when
they feel the need of uh he's not
financially there he's not physically he
doesn't have to be financially why does
why does the kid know if he's not
financially why does somebody have to be
the lead there but why does a man have
to be the financial financier why does
he have to he doesn't have to but what
I'm saying is children did you marry
someone parents responsible no no it's
it's both parents responsibility but
what I'm saying is during covert time my
son decided to approach his dad his dad
was so bitter that he got he came back
to me and I said what happened like you
know go into apartment why was the dad
better he was just bitter and angry but
what me why for leaving him okay so he
was angry that you left him isn't that a
valid reason to be angry yeah I had it
absolutely it will it should be a valid
reason for us to angry but what I'm
saying is staying in a relationship
where you are miserable and making he is
miserable as well is not healthy for you
but I think this is the problem this is
something this is such a modern mindset
it's like marriage isn't supposed to be
about your happiness your happiness is
going to come and go like and you
shouldn't rely on another person to make
you happy if you don't have no
communication with somebody my marriage
was an arranged marriage I never spoke
to the guy on our wedding night I I
never I only met him once before I got
married to him so 18 years living with
somebody who doesn't speak to you and
you're just living in a house and
sleeping together you never talk to you
ever no it's literally just about no I
mean like you guys never had
conversations like this isn't it 18
years exactly you can live with somebody
a lot of times as women like we put our
expectations on men but can I it's like
men don't communicate but men they're
like wait wait wait men don't
communicate the same way we do like men
just want to sit like they don't want to
talk
from a different place I was born I was
born around six brothers in Pakistan so
my my
context about men was very different to
his context of a woman a modern woman
from England right so it was but we
never communicated with each other for
18 years now what I know if I've known
that 18 years ago that would
relationship would have stayed for life
I'm sorry to cut you off this is just
getting a bit out of control I agree uh
viewers this is what happens when it's
only ladies having a conversation in a
room so no please ever please everybody
please everybody just let's ladies let's
just try to have a coherent conversation
I think it's very says to talk like this
is
telling their experiences
the lady are here I know many of them
you don't know the background you were
not to be in this situation and you are
not you don't know anything he's just
observing he's just
waiting
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no can you
Can you mutor mike no you don't get to
just no no no then build your own show
and go build your own show it's like
entitlement you're not entitled like
this is such entitlement I can't no no
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait okay
actually I forgot what I was gonna say
oh sorry did you want to finish your
point I mean I mean after listening to
all of this
I know this might sound crazy
um I saw a tweet you did
um once where you said women shouldn't
be permitted to vote
and yes yes take it away repeal the 19th
yeah yes I I saw it you know
and I could see how you would think that
you know I could see how you think but
I've actually spoken with some women
Harold did you say that oh yeah oh yeah
get rid of it no but but really I I
realize this might sound crazy but the
Tweet you said women it should be
illegal for them to vote and I can I can
see how you would think that
but
I've actually had some conversations
personal ones with women
and I now firmly believe that not all
women
are complete morons
that's actually Alpha King rule number
some women
can actually be
pretty smart sometimes include including
yourself Pearl thank you well you are
married so I'm assuming your wife is a
wonderful woman
she's she's my pride of Joy exactly so
there you go so there are women pearls
Pearl's a great example of uh uh wow
unique one wow thank you oh unique okay
yeah well she's successful entrepreneur
she organized everything here we go no
no no no no no no no no I'm not taking
him the iron the irony one last thing
here one last thing the irony here would
be that someone like Pearl would be
viewed as someone like a far right maybe
but in reality if you look at all her
staff she Embraces uh quite a bit of
diversity in her Staffing so you know
for example she she's created jobs in
this neighborhood she's an employer she
put aside Capital she saved Capital she
built the equipment she took the office
space she built a couple Studios
right she's not counting on a man to
take care of her she's doing everything
all the same as me so can I say
something I'm not doing what pose doing
right now there's some respect no I
don't I don't take nothing away from
pill we have indifferent we have
different opinions so it's nothing
towards pill as a human being and what
she does we have difference of opinion
she doesn't have to respect my opinion I
don't have to respect her opinion or
agree let's say so because just like she
said she wants to take voting away
wherever you said yeah
so for me I find that's the biggest
[__] because only reason why I say
that okay is for example I'm not going
to mention a name because we're not
allowed but during the period that we
went that we've just passed what
countries had the best
rates
all right or the lowest the management
in terms of management were led by whom
we're led by who not men and oh you know
you know where this would actually prove
my point
all of the countries that followed that
stuff right because you're talking about
the job yeah yeah do you know who push
that women yeah women yes but who
created the the thing was it well that
was an owl I'm not even gonna lie
it's very funny how it's very funny how
when we talk about leadership and
countries that are led by women yes the
the president might be a woman but does
that mean that it is the president that
is
um running the country
you might be right you might be wrong so
what you're saying is not facts neither
no but but then you can you can make an
analogy it says that if you were to look
throughout all of human history whenever
you see a woman at the top of anything
there's usually a team of men usually
very competent men helping her to
achieve her goals so we need each other
no no no no no I would say I would say
women need men and men do not need women
outside of reproduction oh my God we
need each other
now so when I'm talking about this is
okay I'm going to clarify what I mean
okay so I'm going to clarify when I'm
talking about running Society so making
Society run take out the reproduction
like raising the kids part I don't think
we need women in society for it to run
now I'm gonna tell you why
because when you look at all the jobs
that men mainly do it holds the
infrastructure of society for example
I'm quite I'm a young I like to think of
myself as young and successful but I
couldn't do what I do without this
building that was built by Men by this
microphone that was built by Men by the
plump without the plumbing that was
built by men how do you know about the
electricity because again I'm a I do I
do look up numbers you know what I mean
I do I do and and yes I am I am a
numbers I am a numbers gal and one and
if you look up the um
sex makeup in those Industries it's 90
plus percent men and what another
observation I had is all the industries
We complain about are mostly run by
women now I'm not saying there are not
exceptions of why I can't wait I'm going
to go into them in a second I am not
saying there are not exceptions of high
IQ women that that cannot make an impact
right but are they necessary not really
now the industries that that now I'm
gonna I'm gonna give you an example
let's talk about the industries that
women run one I found out in the U.S we
have something called the DMV Driver's
License it is known as being so slow and
inefficient that the last movie about
the DMV they made a sloth play the DMV
person because they're so slow education
we're always whining about education and
how bad the education system is and how
they're indoctrinating children women
run that industry Health Care is another
one I I always hear people complain
about and and the other thing is the how
Healthcare is still roughly 50 percent
men and the highest jobs in those
Industries are still men
fourth part I'm sorry one more part and
then I'm gonna I'll I will let you go
the the thing that when you look at
successful female women you know they do
monetize Beauty
and so we can look at Industries where
women dominate it's really Beauty like
it's social media modeling
um and like selling makeup Kim
Kardashian Kylie Jenner they all
monetize Beauty all right
um yes that that is my case as to why I
do not think we think we need women to
run the infrastructure of society I will
let you go and then I'll let you and
then I'll let you go okay go ahead I
have a question yes but yeah are you
suggesting the Health Care system is not
running well because there's a less
woman taking highest responsibility or
what was exactly what you said I've
noticed I I didn't make a definitive
statement about health care I'm not
going to pretend I know your ins and
outs of your health care I've just
noticed a trend where the industries
that women tend to dominate so one of
those is nursing right although women
um and women dominate Physicians but
they don't I dominate the like brain
surgery like the highest form of
medicine but but but I've noticed a
trend that a lot of the industries that
have a lot of women in them are there's
a lot of complaints about efficiency
for example Healthcare is one I hear a
lot of complaints about health care both
here and in the US I hear a lot of
complaints I have to stop you here
because
complained it exists I've worked more
than 20 22 decades working Healthcare
System yes our working minister of
Health in one of the very large
countries in the world okay so is a
woman here okay say as adviser and
consultant Ministry of Health okay we
are researcher there we work in many
University raised a lot of students to
be Midwife and yes and whatever yes
same we had a lot of men we've worked
together there are a lot of men in those
Industries what does it mean that
because men working or women work
women's working in the house I just I
just example that system doesn't work
because of the portion of men and women
no the Health Care System doesn't work
because of the policy that politician
makes and you know
okay so this goes back to my women
voting okay because because no no no but
let me let me let me let me talk yeah
yeah so so I'll give you an example of
this goes who passes those policies if
you talk to politicians which I have
because I wanted to know why the child
support system was so unfair to men so I
was asking why does this stuff like why
is it so biased and the reason is most
um politicians are catering to women
because they have to single women are
the largest voting block
where men tend to stay the same
so like men are much more loyal right
relationships too but also in politics
when men vote this is true when men okay
you don't you don't have to you don't
have to believe it but it is true okay
men tend to stay with their voting block
where women um tend to switch more women
can be bought a lot more than men and
you see this in marriages you know they
they give you guys free housing women
are like we're leaving the men now this
is true look it up 60s in the U.S they
give women free housing and government
handouts and then they start to divorce
their husbands are you actually
comparing societies systemic oh Lord
statistics
right I'm giving you I'm giving you I
just
this is an opinion so this part is an
opinion right you can disagree
can I say I think what you have just
said is in when you put it in practice
it almost it makes it easier for a woman
to leave you don't work at the marriage
you don't you don't want to you don't
want to fix things you don't want to
talk about it you don't want to
communicate it's easier to leave
men and women leave but one's paid to
obviously
but back has other things you know so oh
wait I need I need to I need to finish
one part I'm sorry I'm gonna let you go
I'm sorry one more part and I will I
will but but but the other thing is even
in the industries that women work a lot
in men can easily learn those Industries
men can easily become nurses men can
easily become teachers so if all the
women left the work of course tomorrow
what do you talk okay okay build the
building
okay look at Sophie if you think men
learn easy things sorry
um can we please just remember the rules
it's not just about prose about each
other as well let's stop over talking
each other I know it's hard but we need
to try and [__] okay should should women
be in charge it just really depends on
the women if she's great at soccer
let's let her coach a girls team
but would I let this lady into pink
manage a beauty salon
of course not
it just depends on the position
no no no sorry can you can you emphasize
on what you're saying I don't get like
the point that you made about her
running a beauty yeah I don't get that
it depends on the position it depends on
should women I mean
okay
I don't know if this sounds sexist or
not to the to the viewers but isn't this
sort of show why women get the bad rap
that they get
exactly no no no I feel like this show
this show I'm sorry it almost caters for
misogynist viewers literally because I
agree with pearl to a certain extent my
problem when me and Paul kind of like I
don't agree misogynistic
I gotta address the first part I mean
that's my opinion what is that what is
it okay what is the diet what is the
definition of massages what exactly what
you're saying no what is it what is it
no what is it what is it don't have to
give you a definition
okay if I was exactly no no no no no
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
okay thank you thank you what is the
definition of misogyny
I just if I'm going to call someone
something I know okay okay right the
fact that you just basically everything
that you base and all the information
that you buy okay it caters literally
for men's egos okay right you basically
eradicate every any sort of words about
women
okay
it's not I don't have to tell you the
difference I don't have to Define it
you have an agenda there is an agenda
there's America being played in society
in society there are women who are toxic
and there are women that play a field
that basically push this agenda it's
like basically toxic message so it's the
same thing as toxic femininity it's just
you're basically the opposite basically
let me explain something the reason why
we're asking you to to Define misogyny
is not because we're trying to pick on
you there's a reason we've done this
show if you can look at the the Thomas
that's just my opinion though just one
second you just keep cutting me off
we've done this show this is episode 137
right yeah and every single time a woman
this think about it how many women are
here so we've done 137 episodes that
should tell you that we've probably had
over 600 women on this in this room so
every time a woman has used the word
misogyny she has not known the meaning
of the word so I want to say I told you
no you haven't told us what's the
meaning
you basically I just basically told you
your show is almost like the opposite to
feminism definition what is the
definition of yourself it's sexist it's
very
sex those are all adjectives these are
all adjectives
listen I'm not going because I feel not
know what you guys are basically trying
to sort of do you know what I don't know
what we're trying to do your push an
agenda with a specific type of women and
you generalize all women in that sense
you take away just literally the society
we call it the um
the systemic oppression
disregard the systemic oppression of
women you do are you going to answer it
oh my God I have your opinion and that's
all but here's I can ask you
can you please kindly tell us the
definition
okay then I didn't okay then then you
don't use the word again I mean that's
my opinion but we move but what what
what is untrue and this is the thing
I'll tell you why like because a lot of
you know people think that I'm super
hard on women right
um and my my thing is historically women
are just worse than we've ever been from
a historical point of view it's
unprecedented you know what percent of
women are virgins on their wedding days
this isn't misogynistic I'm about to
give you stats I'm about to give you
guys numbers and stuff so so I mean you
could Google them pretty easy it's
pretty simple it's pretty easy one one
is one is I mean this is what the left
will try to do to like discredit you is
they just question every stat but it's
you can Google them pretty easy okay so
what percent of women what percent of
women do you think are virgins on their
wedding day okay so if someone was to be
aware wait wait it would have to be a
virgin
I just we're gonna we're gonna go we're
gonna go into this later but but I want
to say what percent of women are virgins
on their wedding
in the west all right can we can we
answer the question probably about 25 25
okay who who thinks it's higher
okay all right
it's five percent what percent of women
have been on birth control at some point
in their life
90 but what the average women
okay okay we're okay fine which is all
good and well until we start looking at
the body count statistics where the
where after a woman has had five
Partners her chance of a happy marriage
drops to twenty percent okay so and the
average woman has slept with more than
five men okay which remember
historically a hundred years ago 85
percent of women were virgins on their
wedding nights now what else does the
men get out of marriage they get loyalty
but not today because half of women
leave
then then we start to go into weight
where women are overweight the average
woman is five three hundred and seventy
pounds these are just numbers and yet we
scream misogyny at me but these are
these are just numbers now I'm and it's
like I can't say numbers without being
called sexist when they are true
I'm family therapist and I make big
research and I have a lot of numbers
eighty percent of women I decide to
divorce
that women choose but women choose from
Men Who choose her
women choose but first for example if
you have one room and you have fun five
men from these five men you choose men
who choose you one might make you sick
now I like you I smile you you go and
you choose from man who choose you if
men don't like you if not has sex
attraction you cannot do anything first
man need to go up and say I want this
woman and then you choose from Men Who
choose you first second you're totally
right we are women I make my book about
entrepreneur and it's absolutely in
numbers we are women we are not so smart
like men we cannot make many things
which make men never ever because our
brain is different it's different we
cannot we cannot run so fast we cannot
make some big numbers you are totally
right that the business which make we
are women it's psychologist coach and
Beauty it cannot be my old man and if a
woman for good she's a woman she become
to be sick every day work with women who
cannot be pregnancy today is the biggest
problem in our society in UK and what
they are do they become to be men she
have a lot of cortiso she has opinion
about oh this is it messes up to be a
feminist and after she came to me like
family therapist Natalia I want to be
pregnant what you do 40 years you hate
men you hate your father you try to show
that you have big balls and after
yourself I want to be a woman what you
did before you need first to be a woman
and woman it's a totally different
Quality quality which you need to
survive as a man you need to be strong
and we know usually what woman today
tell to me Natalia I want to find the
man which very kind very rich very good
looking a very sexy love me like a crazy
he's a very crazy to accept my child he
want to take care about him about my
child he wants to marry me and from some
reason he's single in 40 years old
and of course she couldn't find it after
she is very disappointed and you are
right that woman shoes but probably that
women have too high expectation she want
to be a princess she doesn't want to
change herself to go to fitness to take
care about how she looks how she speak
with men how she listen man because the
woman must listen not to speak you need
to speak 10 and 90 you need to listen
and to speak exactly admiring admire
your men admire to him admire him and
about single and separation has big
difference you can be separate with your
partner but he continued to help you he
continued to help your child he
continued to take care about you he
continued to be your best friend and to
call you every time when you need him if
you make normal relationship you must do
divorce only when you have Financial
dependence loyal Independence your
emotional stability you love yourself
you are a love your partner but you can
develop because you say I want something
else and you continue to say your child
your father is the best man in the world
and your child if he can be divorced but
he can love both of parents and not have
psychological trauma you can be in
marriage to be in toxic relationship and
you can destroy your child a woman must
to love it's the most important mission
of women which forgot not compare with
men you are not a man you are a woman I
agree with that can I follow on from
what you're saying I I agree with a lot
of what you're saying in terms of
when women and men wear physiologically
different mentally we're different our
brains are wired differently I think men
crave and demand respect even in
marriage if I don't respect my husband I
can't expect my husband to love me in
the way that I want to be loved if I
don't give him the respect there's a
book I read I can't remember the artist
the artist the author's name it's
literally called respect and love and if
you don't give each to the other one the
other needs and with the other ones it
becomes a crazy cycle so if I don't give
my husband the respect he's not going to
love me the way that I want and he will
give me love but ultimately he wants me
to respect him and not a respect that I
should be submissive and oh yes sir you
know kneeling on the Flory time he says
jump in and say oh how high no he needs
to give me a level of respect too can I
say it will only work if you love and
respect yourself 100 can I just carry on
from what you mentioned when I um when I
started to live with my husband he said
to me that you need to you need to
remember that you have a man because
I'll do things like carry all the bags
independent independently buy myself to
the door and he'd say why didn't you
call me so it's just learning little
things that I had to do to be more
feminine and understand that I am in the
marriage and there are roles I know
people don't like to
um the terminology of gender roles but
sometimes they are in in a marriage or
in a relationship where men need to feel
like they are men they need to feel like
their woman needs them to some extent
and that's what I had to learn I had to
learn I had to relearn how to be
feminine because I was single for so
long I kind of forgotten it by yourself
yeah I've kind of forgot how to depend
on a man I had that with my father Oh
Daddy please Daddy please oh yes yes and
he'd give me whatever I wanted but
that's also the sense of him being
needed my father knew that I needed him
and he provided so it was the same in my
marriage I need you and he provided but
when I don't let him know that he's
needed like me getting up on a chair and
trying to change a light bulb myself I
know how to do it uh-huh but baby can
you come and please you know I don't
really want can you yeah of course he'll
come and do it so it's those little
things that also add to um to making
your man know that you do need him you
might not well you might not need him
but you allow him to feel needed even
though you can do it and that's kind of
the feminine femininity and masculinity
in the relationship the the yin yang the
Yang that goes together collectively
Pearl I would like to just stand up for
your show
um I think they're trying to essentially
say that this show is promoting misogyny
when literally all you did was give all
of these ladies a platform to speak on
it's it's not Pearl's fault that there's
these ladies speak the way they do
for example for example the lady over
here is screaming misogyny yet she
doesn't even know the definition
you know exactly what I meant by carry
on
I don't have to take a dictionary if you
know what I don't have to say to you in
a dictionary English word by word you
know exactly but what I mean but the
reason why you know I just said to you I
basically reply to you is when you take
away where you basically don't
acknowledge don't acknowledge a woman
women go for it a systemic it's almost
it's very that's one male side
it's a form of Oppression it's a form of
Oppression towards women misogyny has a
specific definition
what is it then tell me it's education
I need to reiterate the rules because if
you keep doing this you'll be kicked off
the show unfortunately but the reality
is
whether you like it or not language
exists for a reason women keep talking
about oh communication this
communication that women are better at
communicating than men yet
in the same breath you would say a word
and misuse it and then still argue that
what you think it means is the
definition when it clearly isn't Okay
the reason why I can confidently say
this is because like I said before this
is episode 137 we've done this show 137
times and every single time a woman has
used the word misogyny we have come to
find out that she doesn't know the
meaning so is it wrong for me to be able
to now make an analytical logical
conclusion that you probably don't know
the meaning as well well that's your
opinion it's not an opinion that's your
opinion this is how science is is
propagated unless you gave you examples
of it by you no I started an example
definition if I were to ask you what's
the definition of a woman I'm sure you
probably don't even know that as well
hahaha
I think it's too much attacking to this
Lane 100
.
I think it's better yes
do you know the crazy thing is you've
talked more than anyone like you've
talked to the most of the show out of
all the guests you I'm not even saying
anything no you were just talking the
whole show and you'll say to me pushing
an agenda I can't make words come out of
your mouth and the crazy thing is I'm
just so tired of this narrative that
women are oppressed in any way women are
not ever met women are more likely to
get custody of their CH of their
children women are more likely to get
child support alimony men are more
likely to commit suicide men do the
hardest jobs men are the majority of
workplace deaths and yet women will live
in a society that men built and cry
misogyny and oppression
I have a question from this lady here
um just correct me if in case I
understood wrong you said that men are
more clever than women have I heard it
correctly exactly okay how you can
um how you can prove that they have very
big difficult medical things when
approvement Texas to part of brain and
show The Logical way for example if men
play chess he can play 10 steps they
make the same experiment with women can
be maximum five your brain not have
deepest level which have meant it's
approved it's approved if you're
interested it means IQ it's main IQ it's
meant how deep he can make if you take
all statistic a woman we cook every day
but chefs is always men women can be
nurse but the biggest men who make
operation it's men women can help and
manage things but owner of business
that's meant if you open Forbes because
I'm a big research in my life and I have
academic two high education of
psychology
clinical medical psychology I work in
hospital and I have experience about
this and yes I can say with absolutely
numbers if you're not new you can check
on Google he has something clever much
stronger also try to check in the tennis
faster because they have in all his
biggest we can not we cannot this lady
in the red is you know the lady in the
red is actually nailing it I mean it's
and it's a shame that women like the one
in the red get you know suppressed
canceled uh because she's actually
saying common sense you know I work just
so you know I work with fashion models
in New York for about 10 years I was a
nightclub promoter and I Pearl and I
were talking about this where the the
Eastern European models and comparing
them to the Brazilian models and the
Eastern European ones that were way more
uh traditional submissive
and they respected the man you know they
didn't give a [__] maybe how he looked
Brazilian ones might have loved it they
had fun Playboy but the but the Eastern
European women they had a standard of
expectations of what they wanted from a
man they wanted a strong man they placed
that higher as a life partner but then
they were willing to give that in return
the problem is when women want all X Y
and Z but they're not when it suits them
but then they also want X Y and Z when
it you know they want their cake and
they eat it too man it just it can't
work that way it doesn't work that way
and I think you I think you you describe
I think I think I I don't have very much
discussion over whatever you said is I'm
completely disagree when you said men
are more clever than women because I'm
in clinical field as well okay so I'm
working in the hospital as well and IQ
we have seven types I just seven types
of IQ that you know recognize we have a
sport IQ have a math IQ have it either
you can say generalize that women are
less clever how many discovered it has a
woman how many Discovery how many
discoveries has a woman okay how many
children have how many philosophic has a
women how many uh artists has the women
no open Google no this is billionaires
let's talk about the billionaires the
richest women billionaires divorce
that's the funniest thing the most
successful women got their money why
from my divorce has my relationship with
the IQ um
but I'm asking about outcomes so the
women with the most money how did they
get there was it was it through being so
smart and competent
let's let's let's think about I'm
thinking about our female billionaires
one has a sex tape one sells makeup and
the others got their money Amex model
yeah and I work in healthcare when Amex
model you're you're a model I'm a model
okay and you work in healthcare and I
work in a healthcare yes okay great and
I have a black belt in karate okay but I
bet you he could still say and if you
say that Romans are not clever
we can't say who is aware we have to say
I think we can look at the outcomes so
we could see who who is not an outcome
is which category you know the men can't
be a better Runner if the if they run
with women because they have testosters
they have a bigger muscles okay not
because they are more clever they active
you know the sport IQ then they hire but
you can compare this lady with this lady
okay this man comparing the man you said
once one time you said men are different
with women their brain is different
their size is different and then you
compare the IQ together it's absolutely
wrong exactly absolutely I'm looking I'm
looking at it
well I don't not beautiful I'm not
talking about beauty no you said Beauty
I said we monetize I I said okay let's
talk about value added to Society what
makes Society run okay no no no no wait
wait wait wait wait wait let me let me
love you I need you remember remember
Mike again all right this is your final
warning one more time you're gonna go
okay so
I'm sorry okay I think it's very
important all right thank you thank you
all right all right what did you say
respect your guess okay actually you can
go now thank you goodbye yeah goodbye um
Security will escort you out
wow yeah that was pretty yeah I I've
warned you like three times
to stop over talking me we read you the
rules at the beginning of the show it's
all right go ahead everyone
no all right and now you're gonna keep
talking back goodbye goodbye Go please
uh exclude my conversation and
everything from this video no it's live
so I'll see ya
you didn't invite me I didn't want to
yeah but calling the people
I vote
okay
okay all right I have eight years old
waiting for me okay all right
okay I mean if you knew all that you
could have just followed the rules
though
because
stop over talking and even while you
were doing it just now she still told
you okay stop stop stop but you just
didn't yeah y'all see how y'all see how
it's like y'all see how her emotions
just took over though right it's just a
clear example of how everything she was
saying was [__]
um
thank you
no no she doesn't no go take out you
take yourself okay no no no no no no
that's not yourself no no no
no no please leave please leave
can you just leave please
this is this is the problem it's not
working like actually just leave please
no take her out take her out can I just
say I don't take her get out get out
that's on Big Bang don't worry about it
it's just a it's just a show it's just a
show
it's just a show
it's just a show I respect you but it I
just just sit down and have a good show
I don't want you to leave no no good I
don't look good right now she's go just
please be respectful that's all she's
saying
okay yeah just watch out bro watch out
bro she's a black belt in karate
crazy it's like there's a Black Bottle
karate saying watch out you
foreign
yes goodbye goodbye goodbye
outside
oh
I don't remember what we're talking
about
um
yeah I don't care go ahead
can I speak so you said you're a
psychologist
yeah yeah
why do you think why do you think why do
you think men are more clever what's the
psychology behind that you know it's
about to understand who you are and
which energy you have more female or
male of course exist now a lot of male
women where are you where are you from
for example oh I'm like a long story I
born in Russia after I live many many
years
um I have experience in marriage 19
years and I know all about relationship
and we're sure in something men they're
very strong and we need to respect them
and some think women they're very strong
and women were most drunk and emotional
you are right that men cannot live to
live without us and we also give
inspiration of men and we have very big
role for men and women just need to
understand what is your role well my
issue is I'm not just talking about the
infrastructure Society so it's like if
we're not doing if we're not making the
most money if we're not doing the most
dangerous jobs how can we say we have an
equal impact as men when it comes to
running Society it's the biggest problem
biggest problem and the problem if men
make less money than women very often
it's disappear sexual attraction because
automatically we are women not because
we want money money from and of course
so it's great I like to receive gifts
help of men but if men all time have
less money than women he come to be her
son
and she doesn't respect him we are women
we must respect men who are stronger and
bigger than us otherwise we can very
like him you can know my son you're my
cute boy and we become to be like mother
and son and man inside us he also hid if
we are more stronger because he not feel
correct and not feel good with us and
it's uh before many years when we live
in cave might go he take one big meal
and say her wife it's your meal eat it
and she cooked and cheated now a woman
say you know a meal a meal which you
gave me it's not enough I can make it
faster and bigger yeah and the woman
says stay home and Cave take care about
child I go to make a huntering I will
take a man I will take a meal and now
I'm uh begins to switch your headphones
just so you know so you take off that
ones you have put those on just because
otherwise it's gonna yeah there you go
by the way I'm curious no by the way
while you were gone did you uh look up
the definition of misogyny no know why
would you want me to look well we're
still going on this on this thingy me
saying that if I fit five if I feel I
don't understand what the issue is it's
my it's an opinion that I have that I
feel there's a lot of things that go
again
but that's that's like me calling
someone fat and not knowing what that is
good if you're doing things against
women or okay
what is against women like I just want
to know what is against women what do
you mean what is against because you say
I say things that are against women what
is against women can I say something oh
I think I'm not hello I'm not going to
speak for you hello I'm not going to
speak for you it's when you're online
not racist but when you're not it's not
like Sexes and Prejudice towards certain
[Music]
and it's okay for me to feel that way
this is my feeling this is my opinion
from this is just off the back of what
you're saying there's some statements
that people can make and as yourself as
a host that you've made it puts the
women in a negative light oh we know
what do women's uh are they true what it
might not be true that's your opinion
you're saying facts and all of that we
can go and Google we're not we're not
allowed to be on off and that's part of
the rules right I'm sure if I could go
on Google right now and bring out
something I can break up some facts same
way this lady here Natalia she's
researched and done some studies she's
got her her area of expertise there's so
many women as well that have contributed
loads of you know perfect things not
perfect things loads of great things in
society look at when you know England
and whatever went to war and all the
soldiers went who were called to come
and help rebuild wait wait wait who is
defending the society though they
couldn't even work in the factories if
the men were defending the society okay
but that's it shows up how they were
part of the infrastructure they were
able to help rebuild they were showed
that they had a purpose they were able
to help but they still didn't do the
thing that was the most necessary which
was defending Society
now women go out to war now
do you know what's crazy one um women
can't become Navy SEALS or whatever the
highest tax a lot because they can't
physically do it and they're lowering
standards of the military because they
want to include women which I think is a
bad thing I think they keep telling us
we're equal to men and we are not I
think they keep saying that we can do
the same things that men can do and we
cannot I don't think that makes me mean
or misogynistic I think it's it's true
there are certain things that physically
women cannot do that only men can do to
a certain degree you have categories the
same way in Olympics you're not going to
put a woman to compete against a man
because physiologically you can't
compete if there's a weightlifting
Championship women there's a
weightlifting Championship women
do right okay so if you enter a man's
world then compete be a man and if you
can't do it but they don't do that
though the thing is they're going to
have categories women are going to
compete against women men are going to
compete against men when there's a race
you were talking about women can't run
as fast it's been fine we can accept
that so you raise you stay in your lane
you stay in your category correct you
race against those and women can be fast
is women do not do the hardest jobs in
society some women do it's very much an
exception about brain surgeons who are
women
scientists it is the exception it is not
the rule of conventions 80 of things
that are invented were bi and the rest
of the 20 the 20 the remaining 20 are
women what and I just want to know what
is women what is holding us back
how do we know it was actually men who
invented these things because if I came
up with an invention and I said babes um
progress this for me please I'm sure he
would be happy I just want to understand
I just want to understand your premise
so your premise right now is that all
the inventors it was their wives
actually
but it's so crazy because when a woman
accomplishes something we never say oh
it was probably the man behind her in
general and I might do that but but in
general in society right but vice versa
it's like we we say all of the things
that that men have accomplished we
attribute them to women in some way
probably because historically men were
the leaders in society women are told to
be quiet as you mentioned previously we
listen more so even if we do even if we
did invent something it would be the men
to carry it Forward because they are
true one of the first one of the
earliest millionaires in in the U.S one
of like the very first millionaire was
was a woman and she I don't remember
what she invented but she eventually
yeah yeah and so and this is like
another this is a I can't I can't answer
but I know she was the first female
millionaire and this is like um this
this is a narrative that woman couldn't
have Heist have couldn't be influential
in society that women could didn't talk
it's just incorrect there are like
Cleopatra Joan of Arc there have always
been high IQ women that have been very
impactful in society there have been
um queens and rulers that men have
traveled thousands of miles to get
wisdom from this idea that women just
could not get ahead is not true
women can get ahead and if we're gonna
go on facts obviously I can't bring up
my facts now but we know that that women
have been silenced in in many situations
if you look at different cultures
different contexts you know women don't
have the same voice or not given the
same voice or the opinion to speak up as
men or even if they do speak they're not
her because we mean your places to stay
on the side you know be something no but
I'm saying that's not true it's true in
certain contexts
two things can be true at once it that's
the thing we have to look at things in
you know perspective in a big
perspective just because it's not true
here it doesn't mean it's not true but
it's like but it's like whatever but
whenever I like refute a point it's like
you guys are like jumping through hoops
to try to make us the victim I'm not
making you I'm sorry
women are not victims
because you mentioned Nigeria yeah back
in the day if you were to trace it back
into history because she's very right
women have always not Society has never
said and it has never been in law where
women can't do anything yes the reality
is most people throughout history
couldn't do anything it was usually the
elites and the rich people that could do
stuff and the women in those Realms
could do whatever they wanted to do yes
of course they were why why do we know
Cleopatra's why do we know why do we why
do we know why do we know all the female
inventors CJ Walker yes this woman that
helped to release slaves in America
um
because if you are excellent you will be
celebrated the reason why most people
are not women were oppressed is because
most people were seen as less than all
throughout history at the time yeah so
it wasn't women that were being
oppressed women were being oppressed in
a certain way and men were being
oppressed in a different oh I agree with
that I agree with you because even women
I know we're not going to make it about
race but even when we look at race that
was so many people have been getting
oppressed because of race and it's the
same way you can race as a category so
it's a social construct you know women
yes we are physiological you can Mark Us
by the way we are that's women but men
don't necessarily look at your body and
see okay she's women they will look at
you you know you're talking about all
Society society as well how Society
thinks
that's how they look at you as a woman
they would they will put you know
perspectives and mindsets on you because
you're a woman I know I think you have a
privilege as a woman I think it's easier
I think you're more if you know
your advantage
no I think as a young woman you have so
much privilege in society more than men
yeah in general yes absolutely it
depends
because I have six brothers and when I
first come to England there are certain
comments my brothers made and they were
more like but it's easier for you being
a woman and I do agree with that there
are certain things special culture it's
much harder for them you know as a man
to go out and start like for us we can
get
and like you said we get attracted by so
many men they want to take care of us
it's much easier for us I totally well
and there's so many women's shelters
that help us yeah there are no men's
shelters yeah it's true
what are you talking about women's
shelters what the abuse yes there's what
about what about male victims of abuse
because it's a highly disproportionate
no it's actually so so the majority the
majority no no because why the majority
the majority the majority the majority
of abuse is mutual meaning they are both
hitting each other yes and so and so and
you know what's crazy was when they
looked into it they found that one-sided
abuse it was more likely the woman to
hit the man and the man and the other
part we don't talk about is all the
false abuse allegations especially in
this country because there are
incentives for women to falsely accuse
men of abuse because what they do is
they expand the definition of abuse and
to goddamn anything they have Financial
abuse emotional abuse they've expanded
it and what what they do is there is
incent Financial incentives for women to
falsely accuse men
because they get free lawyers in child
support or in um Family Court I'm not
taking that away for you from you but
the percentage is extremely small so no
it's actually exactly so it's actually
it's a roughly I can't remember exactly
but it's around for roughly 10 to 20
percent of women that file abuse and
family court actually go to criminal
court and in family court it's based on
a balance of probabilities that's
actually not based off of evidence but
it's not it's not based on I'm guilty
it's basically guilty until proven
innocent or vice versa and I have a lot
of experience interviewing these guys
and family
organizations out there that do support
male men can be victims of domesticated
however however it's because of society
how we've used how we view men men are
meant to be strong you're meant to be a
leader oh my God no way can a man come
forward and say my wife abuses me yes
you're right there's so many categories
when it comes to domestic abuse not just
physical it can be Financial it can be
mental it can be so many other you know
aspects so a man will feel shame a
mouthful shame you know God forbid he's
to come out and say oh my God I mean
there are organizations that do support
them I don't know about shelters
real quick yes to your point are women
better at some things than men yes for
example for example if you and I were to
box I would probably win but I can
almost guarantee you that you can suck
[__] better than I can
what do you not have a mouth it's the
same mouth that you're going to use if
you're going to suck [__] isn't it so
who's it what that's the same house
I have a conversation and be mature I
have a bottom lip and I have a top lip
and I have a tongue so do you so if you
want to suck [__] you go ahead and do
that I'm not gonna compete with you now
if you don't want to have a mature
conversation I'm being mature
I don't know how we went from domestic
abuses
that's just the silly
I'm not sure
I've not one to intervene but I came
here invited to this podcast
I I got here it took me two hours to
drive here I looked at no disrespect to
anybody but I've never been to this part
of London I'm petrified even getting out
of my car here I don't belong in this
side of the world I belong in the
countryside I I gotta now get out in the
dark get to my car with this dude
security guy who I love thank you you're
gonna take me to my car but I did not
come here to have conversations about
cook I don't even use them if you give
somebody to speak to your wife like that
we told you would you like that if I
never would actually agreeing with you
no no that's not how you agree
sorry I'm so sorry
you need to understand Italian
Natalia
[Applause]
[__] wait wait wait King go ahead
um guys please can we just remember the
rules yeah I get it we're all having fun
but let's just try and because we have
people at home watching yeah okay it's
disrespectful to me but hold on I've
raised my hand so I do want to make a
point next yeah I mean what did you say
before I just want to ask you she said
men think about [__] all the time so I
just want to carry around with my point
I'm making no problem and going off on a
point you said I mean this is not why I
came here on this podcast to talk about
Cork and whatever and to me I do find
that disrespectful yes cook is aware of
everyone who use that however the point
that I was made I don't remember the
point I was making before because your
point I found it disrespectfulness
I can't control the entire conversation
we can't we can't but we're talking
about respectful that was part of the
rules but we need to respect each other
and I felt disrespected if somebody came
and spoke too off about that being a
married man is that would you be happy
about that I thought we're having I'm
sorry I thought I was invited here to
talk about adult issues I think all the
ladies are being highly offensive
disrespectful to Pearl who's given all
of you ladies this great platform I was
invited here
I had a difference of opinion that's all
I think personally do you feel like we
are disrespecting yeah you guys have
been quite rude a lot of you yeah what
are the things that you do say is very
offensive right but you can you can be
offended you know you can be offended
and still not over talk people and and
cry and scream into the mic like
sometimes you know I've been offended
plenty of times on shows and I don't you
know over talk people cry and scream
into the mic especially on a show that's
not mine by the way the definition of
misogyny is the dislike contempt you
know and disdain of women so Prejudice
so you basically said exactly what no no
no no
women
see she's doing it again there it is
okay okay
this is the crazy thing and they say I'm
pushing an agenda and yet this is this
is how you act it's a shame it's like
it's a shame Pearl's not getting a Nobel
Peace Prize
honestly that you deal with this five
nights a week no well not anymore at one
point I have another interesting
question what's the meaning of prejudice
ask yourself that no because no don't
come here
it is it is you know what come on come
on
she yells over everybody and cries about
this okay that is
what's the definition of prejudice
you're gonna do it
too bad she's overweight it's like the
fat baby mom is gonna talk to me about
being married get out of here get out of
you started man you started man yeah
yeah goodbye I'll see ya okay then
please leave she's just wow what up wow
wow wow yeah wow
can I say something if you want women to
look good ma'am ma'am ma'am if you want
women to look good please please just
stop talking
[Music]
oh yeah yeah the fat the fat baby mama
is coming at me okay
her divorce say I don't remember okay
I don't really you know I'm just trying
to be
okay all right she she came at me first
otherwise I wouldn't have said anything
um can we get the Nigerian lady to come
back I feel better come back please come
back don't be like this don't be like
this come back
no but don't leave huh
I respect you okay I respect you just
please come sit down and be polite and
have an adult conversation yeah don't
act like a baby come sit down come sit
out right now come sit out right here
right now when I'm talking to you I'm
talking to you come sit out right now
please hey I'm talking sit down I can't
sit down
are we going I'm going unbelievable no
the disrespect the disrespect of how you
talk to me now after I tell you to sit
down
after I tell you the [__] I said I'm
sorry to come sit down right there
foreign
ful bro yo honestly did you guys put up
with this [__] this was bad this isn't
particularly bad that was that was
highly disrespectful it honestly was
just immature Pearl yeah I mean it's uh
it's so funny she's still filming are we
still here I'm live it's live it's live
right here you could come to the front
if you want she talked to me like that
can you come on the sofa she ever talk
to me like that yeah you can uh what did
you say no no I was oh I was talking to
her but I mean you can if you want to be
a month screen yeah no I was just like
we can come forward yeah I have a
feeling the last woman will be standing
today
[Laughter]
you know after uh say that the man very
violence when women start to Scream Wait
for again about
um physiology when women scream you can
sit down men cannot listen that yeah oh
okay I was just saying if you want to
sit in any of the front Okay yeah okay I
feel safer at the back okay
okay sorry go ahead sorry I'm sorry when
women scream men
he feel very bad because his ears he
cannot listen very high voice
he wants immediately to stop it to shut
up it it's very irritate him if women
want men to listen here you need to
speak very calm and slowly and then you
have biggest chance to be hurt
exactly woman gentle it's not okay I'm
gonna make him carry all the bags I'm
learning so much forget the boast for
the fourth time
you've been divorced four times pretty
much girl how not can I can I ask you
about it I won't I'm not I'm not trying
to come at you I'm just curious no no
sure so the first time um I I always
exaggerate my numbers but the first time
it was an arranged marriage in my home
country okay it lost it did there was no
marriage it was just like my mom said
get married we did the Islamic marriage
okay
um we never spoke he went home after the
function I stayed in my home and
literally 24 hours I was like Mom I
can't believe you did this not not going
to do it so it ended up in a divorce but
it was a marriage okay
um the second one was my husband of
nearly 20 years I've got two children I
got married at 19. had my first wow you
look you look young I wasn't expecting
you 20 years wow okay so yeah my son is
18. okay
um my oldest is 18 and that lasted about
20 years
and that just recently ended in divorce
okay and now I'm on number three oh
you're married again you have trapped
someone else now okay well I'm just
curious why did the 20-year one end
um
I think we took each other for granted
okay yeah we I have to take
responsibility it wasn't just him we
took each other for granted he was
always working he was the breadwinner
um he was running the home and I was
I was
we took each other for granted okay so
what is it I hear this sometimes I just
don't really understand what it means
it's uh well they like were you nagging
on him didn't appreciate that what you
mean on your side that's the problem I
never nagged um I mean I felt like there
were three of us it's like Princess
Diana there were three of us in this
marriage it was me him and his iPhone
and when I had the kids I put on a lot
of weight uh I mean double of what I am
now but I put on a lot of weight I
became a new I was a full-time mom
um I let myself go but he was a
gentleman and you know all he did was
work
pay the bills
function the home I bought up the kids
and
uh one day I just got really insecure
because he was speaking to somebody and
she said she's going to get liposuction
in turkey and I think he was speaking
with this woman too frequently I didn't
like it but I was a fat mum at home and
I thought oh my goodness I need to start
losing some weight I lost weight I lost
too much weight
so I attracted too much attention from
outside and
sorry excuse me sadly I think um
our marriage deteriorated because of the
weight loss issue I don't understand so
you got too much attention from other
men and so then you divorced him it it
wasn't that I think it we I let other
people into my home into my life and I
that respect wasn't there in a way so
you didn't respect him anymore I
I didn't because I was speaking with
other people when I know I shouldn't
have been and I mean it's I I actually
appreciate you being honest about it
yeah so so you were speaking to other
people and that kind of deteriorated the
marriage it did yeah I did I think it
did yes yeah well I mean
now you're married again
yeah only islamically okay yeah not
civil I would never go down the Civil
route again I just think it's a man-made
world out there they want to suck your
money out when they when you do the
Civil ceremony you pay for it when you
get divorced you pay for it when you
have a function you pay for it it's just
um for me it's a money-making thing I've
seen it all in do you do you in
hindsight when men men a lot of times
will say if your girl starts losing
weight you should be worried do you
think that's true 100 I think you should
lose weight together yeah and just never
forget don't disrespect each other who
are you doing this for are you doing it
for yourself you're doing it for each
other you I mean I did it to try and
keep my husband to keep him entertained
with me so he wouldn't go anywhere else
but um we should have done it together
if I could go back another 10 years we
should have done it together it should
have been something we did it's so
interesting to me it just seems like
when I hear the story and I've just done
so many of these it's like I hear the
stories of divorce I never hear like
real reasons you know and I'm not I
don't mean this to like disrespect you
but I just it just seems like this stuff
can be worked out it can be yeah it can
be and we love honest you're very honest
yeah we lie we make the other person
look bad and we don't take
responsibility so this is why I'm not
out there to make any man
field or look back but women they do
they hide things they they lie they
manipulate I've seen it I've I've Seen
It All I've literally seen it all yeah
how crazy was that screaming I don't
know how you do it Pearl honestly it's
usually not this bad this was the worst
show I was like Jerry Springer you know
what I mean in London no I know I was
like Jesus that was crazy and I used to
tell her she was like screaming at me
but how unhappy I was I'm like I'm
having a good day
she was insulting me first yeah so
almost you lost them you brought emotion
into it too and it's a very feminine
thing to do to bring emotion into oh
yeah we I I just think if women you know
you're if you want to insult me I will
insult you back yes I will no you don't
lower yourself no no no I will I'm sorry
sorry I will yeah I'm not a perfect
person technically that's not an insult
that's just a description yeah
is it true
I think it comes with age and it comes
with wisdom and I think when somebody is
saying something you don't lower
yourself you don't behave like them
because if you do you're as bad as them
yeah yeah
I think it's worse yeah yeah technically
technically I was just describing her
that's what she is based on her that's
like saying if a man punched me in the
face I shouldn't punch him back in the
face no that's self-defense that's
self-defense but this was self-defense
as well
you can't you can't come into someone's
home insult them and then when they
insult you back you start saying well
you shouldn't lower yourself to my level
maybe just say leave yeah which I did
and she didn't leave no but it's an
insult enough when you've said leave get
out of my property that's an insult
enough yeah but it's like she's in my
home yeah yeah
right yeah
um
we're gonna talk about I want to hear
more about your experience as a
psychologist so what what do you you do
psychology I have dedication clinical
medical psychologist sexologist and
family therapist okay and I work it's
also very funny when it's become to be
stressed up how immediately he changed
topic about sex it's very normally for
men if women will wake up every morning
your man with blow job goes I promise
you it's your man a less worse less
problems less conflict in this world
very often when you start to fight just
make a sex and after sex a lot of
conflicts will disappear what do you
what do you see the difference between
Russian women and Western women
um I work with a lot of American women I
work with every word and a lot of Europe
I never work in Russia okay I left when
I was a student and I always work on
Europe and America
and I noticed but from my for example my
mother lives with my father 45 years and
they are very happy we are three
children they have
six grandchildren and we continue to be
always together and support each other
my uh two ex-husbands they love me a lot
they support me a lot is my best friends
they are always common together
my my stepmother always crazy about me
you know divorce it's not end
you can love so much each other we go to
the holidays we make today oh the
birthday it's very normal from people
who develop and mature for me not normal
when people divorce and fight I don't
understand it and in my experience you
my mother always respect my father but
always you oblige to respect and always
she put my father up than children she
always say your father's sleeping now
it's my time with father and until today
she so admired him say see how beautiful
your father he's 75 and he still work my
father until now take care about my
mother take care on holiday my gifts
flowers all my husband always take care
about me until today I make me gifts and
they care about me because it's normal
but I really admire and respect all of
them I really respect my father and I
will always appreciate him he's not
perfect but it's my father and I always
will love him I obviously loves my
ex-husband and father of my child Always
Forever and Always you respect him and
always only good words and very
appreciate him and it's normally
behavior when you are like this in my
business I was in Forbes one of the most
successful entrepreneur in Bulgaria and
Men helped me to make business I really
respect myself
thank you no no no thank you because
most women that are actually successful
I know but that's that's we will always
acknowledge like I can always tell the
like boss babe do it on my own that
mentality as a woman will get you
nowhere in business I am where I am at
because I've listened to men smarter
than me you know I uh my first I was
many years in until today in media
business and has the first show about
sex in Bulgaria okay and has a man Like
Larry King here in Bulgaria he invited
men together with him we make our TV
show it was a revolution because never
people speak about sex so openly and
after him has many projects about
coaching psychology but always I
remember that man helps me you cannot
make successful business if not have
mind on your back my husband helped me
my friends helped me men help me always
well and you know what I realized too do
you know what I hate and I hate this to
my core women that think they're better
than men because they make more money
because just because it's like I make a
lot for a girl right but well I mean I I
do well and I make more than a lot of
men but I'm not better than the guy that
built the building because I wouldn't be
able to do any of this without men but
it's like we have made women's lives so
comfortable that we don't realize we
need men I need a man when they to
protect me if anyone breaks in I need a
man to build the building I need a man
to do the plumbing I need a man to do
the electricity I need a man to invent
stuff it's like the successful women
cannot do what they do without men and
so it irritates me to my core when we
get to a certain point and then [__] on
them as a thank you because we couldn't
get there in the first place one example
I see of this is like Chelsea Handler
you know she she's turned into like a
man-hater when she couldn't even do
comedy without the microphone she
couldn't do comedy without the building
she couldn't do comedy without
Ticketmaster which was invented by a man
oh wait you can unmute her microwave
without that was a girl from earlier go
ahead go ahead no I totally agree with
you like we cannot work in isolation and
say is it working yeah yeah we can hear
you now okay so having six brothers and
around men all my life like you know
even now when I'm single I've got so
many men friends and there are things in
my house like if the balcony is changing
or that fresh thing has broken I always
say oh I wish there's a man there or
somebody or I'll call a man to come and
do the job and definitely this world
can't
you know work without them and equally
like you know for us women definitely
there is like uh an element of they
bring protection they bring security
they are more stronger which I feel like
even in my religion if you look at
Muslim um as a religion we pray behind
men and I love that about it because
there is there is a sense of like
security we are emotional yeah we are
emotional we need to be taken care by
men like you know brought up with six
brothers I I have that you know I have
that thing of it gives you strength
actually it really does like you know so
there is no going uh back about a woman
can no we can't no we literally can't we
just literally come in the crazy thing
in all of history we have not needed
women in the workforce yeah we have not
I'm not saying there are not Exceptions
there are but as a whole we have not
needed them so why do we think now is
different like why is now special
is it
um that's a very good question I think
obviously
because we it's it's just the mindset
has changed to
um
we we like a lot of people say to me
you're a very strong woman and you're
very powerful woman and it just
sometimes I was like no I'm not I need I
need this kind of help but it's just the
more people say that to me you're very
strong the more I get labeled as
somebody oh a man doesn't need to take
care of in fact in my last relationship
I felt like that's what happened that he
perceived me as so strong that he's just
like you don't need me and I'm like I do
like yeah but it's just the way
positioning of okay I have to be
responsible for my kids I'm living on my
own you know that kind of thing and it's
it's it's like it's that perception how
do you
my question is how as a woman you
balance it all that you can still go out
like being a finance director of a
company I didn't choose that career I I
fell into from and then I started loving
finance and numbers and I'm passionate
about it to make a difference at
workplace Etc
um but I don't necessarily call myself
uh I'm I'm a career woman yeah I would
love to be at home and be somebody
smiles and serve him that's what I did
for 18 years with the man I was with
it's just there was no communication
there was nothing there in the sense of
I don't I don't know I just don't get
that I know I think what happened he
told culture isn't it it's the Pakistani
I think the culture I think what
happened and what he shared with me in
the end was
um why he didn't communicate with me
from from literally the wedding night is
he thought he's bringing a girl from I
think he wasn't ready to get married and
he was pushed into it because they
wanted the younger brother to get
married so he married a girl from
Pakistan who uh couldn't even vary
because he wanted me to wear heels to
fly back here like you know on my plane
Journey back and my father-in-law had
the keys for the suitcase and bags and I
did go to my father-in-law I said can I
have so I can take the heels out and he
said no it's okay closed captioning not
available
and like how I'm talking today you have
met me 10 years ago I was a very quiet I
actually enjoy when he comes home I get
the dinner ready how should be super
clean my kids should be in bed I love
nurturing that motherly instincture even
like hearing this I just don't hear a
real reason for divorce yeah yeah no
this is just because it was more of uh
um when I married him uh he was in
financial debt and he keep getting
himself into financial debt okay again
it was more Finance I ate more Finance
for him he he he's was really into
branded stuff and then he loses contract
and I always go and support him like I
went out worked paid his debt off okay
it was keep I keep building him and it
was keep going down and I think it has
an impact on me like there was no
stability with the two kids um and I
then made a decision and I said it's not
healthy for him it's not do you know but
you know what confuses me because like
wouldn't it still be more expensive
because then it's two rents instead of
one he went back to his mom's house uh
and uh uh he did financially no I'm just
curious because I just hear this stuff a
lot a lot of times it just doesn't make
sense it's not like I have tried to like
five years I give it back and forth back
and forth and I even promised his mother
once he's never coming back I'm taking
care of him yeah but I think so he was
like a son husband yeah exactly but
having two kids and him three of them
with financial pressures I felt like I
broke down at that stage and I said I
can't do this anymore when I say
something we're good we're um uh we're
gonna react I'm gonna Read Super chats
right now and then we're gonna react to
a video okay which I wanted to do
earlier but you know this is
conversation got a little derailed I
will say that is my weakness as a host
sometimes is controlling the craziest
Myron does a really great job it's
harder than you think I used to think
Myron was really harsh on the women I
really did but he does such a great job
of like keeping everyone in line much
better than me let me tell you God no I
mean I would say uh my experience on
fresh and fit and then my experience
here with you you and Myron have a lot
in common
I think I think you guys the way you are
you both uh you know run a really clean
operation yeah well I just met he does
such a good job of like like he does
such a good job of not letting people
like over talk each other yeah like that
that whole thing would not have gone on
like half as long if he was you know
what I'm saying yeah but you go hard
though too yeah both of you go home both
of you are welcoming too yeah
um okay so I'm gonna
um read the super chats right now uh
Glenn Lawrence is in the chat
um okay guys
like the video how many likes are we at
right now King I just accidentally
exited out how many likes we got
363 363 guys let's get to a thousand
likes and we will open up the chat
um okay Glenn Lawrence if you are
overweight and get called overweight
that is not bringing emotions into it
and yes the girl in The Red Is Right
ladies you can solve more problems with
um Your Man by giving him that
Glenn um I wish I could call in 93 toe
pie watch the women defend the rude
guests because women have to stick
together till death another rude women
will be born because of women have high
of our Mo because emotions are high now
um and then he said look I told you so
um Ramirez I'm Nina is king
um
Rumble rocks um a black belt and Karen
um Sam's finest what's up with the dude
in the pink dress getting castled
um
uh Frenchie
um already
all right all right and um a black lady
with the braids are perpetuating the
negative um stereotypes black women are
attributed as a young black lady I find
you both utterly embarrassing you're way
too old do better
um Nina Jax also got our super chats for
a kick out cam we are saving for a kick
out of Camp Blessing has maxed out my
credit card the last six months I'm
basically broke because of blessing
um so you know if you guys want to kick
out cam so the next time you guys can
get a full shot
of any ladies that's screaming in my
face okay if you wanted the full room
everyone's reaction so it's probably
were pretty funny we missed out on this
because no kick out cam also big shout
out to security it's his first day on
the job you know and three now let's
give it let's give a round of applause
security yeah
um Nina Jax um the ladies role playing a
victim I swear acting like a child so
emotional Nina Jacks the panel needs
therapy oh my God the emotional trauma
is nuts
um
okay also all right I think that's all
the super chats can we do the second
video I sent you
which was the single mom
uh I sent you a second email
yeah that one
we can we can do that one and then
um
the Joe the Lolo Jones or whatever
second but we'll do that one first
okay
I want to read this really quick because
we do have some people can you turn this
music off I'm a nervous system it's
gonna get copyrighted actually no no go
back King no don't go back
um so I want to read this really quick
make the make the sound off please sound
off
turn the sound off of the video please
okay okay yeah it played again
okay so doing it all by myself hits hard
sometimes
working cooking cleaning and paying the
bills making sure everyone has
everything they need making sure they're
happy what about me
so my question is do single mothers
deserve sympathy
she needs five mans what when you're a
single mother
question why you're single if you have
two hands two legs go out meet at the
moment has so many single months eighty
percent of people divorces means that
every day some single men go on the
street on the gym they live on you there
are so many and when you need to choose
you need to have not one man
minimum five you don't need to sleep
with them but you need to communicate
and to understand what you want what
you're looking for because if you are
very disappeared oh my God oh my God I
need a man I need a man if you take
first you will keep him and you will
very afraid to lost him and if you make
a lot of mistakes you need to have
around you five men two meet to
communicate to receive flowers and to
ask about help use your mouse it's very
good so let's go so your your answer is
go find a man yes okay great go ahead
for me it's no a single mom doesn't
require sympathy because he chooses to
be in that position and I think all she
needs is empowerment but not definitely
not sympathy because it makes it worse
for her poor me saying us we are poor
actually it's like you are cutting our
wings like you know to be that human
being like we need to take
responsibility of what we are doing like
you know we chooses that life it's like
when we sign that marriage certificate
so when I divorced him I was very clear
of I was the one who signed that
marriage without it was an arranged
marriage but nobody put gun on my face
not my parents that you have to do it I
was the one I in fact went to my grandma
inside because they are the one who
arranged it and I said no
make sure you don't feel sorry or feel
bad for me because I was the one it was
your choice it was very clear my choice
because if I have said no in that moment
and didn't marry him I would have been
single and gone somewhere else I choose
him
and I had the choice regardless of how
much I was developed not developed no
not known eight full responsibility lie
with us and I think sympathizing makes
it worse for us because then we indulge
in this emotion and we don't even do the
basic things we need to do you know to
make our life better you're actually
making a woman weaker by sympathizing
with them I do believe in that I
strongly believe in that I I agree
because women abuse sympathy yeah abuse
it yeah what do you think do single
mothers deserve sympathy
yeah I think single mothers uh deserve
sympathy I I lived with a single mother
for a while and uh my own mother she
really worked hard and uh I have a great
wife who wakes up two three o'clock in
the morning to take care of our daughter
and uh and then she'll wake up at like
four my daughter screams and she'll wake
up at like six
and uh I could only imagine if she had
to work I take care of everything for my
my wife okay okay uh but I couldn't
imagine if she didn't have a husband and
if I wasn't there and uh and she was
alone having to wake up at night
and then also work I mean when your
baby's crying doesn't matter how high
your IQ is how much money you got how
much you're good at business or Sports
the mother has the warmth of her of her
of her breast milk and the baby really
only wants that breast milk from the
mother I can't I if I hold my daughter
at 3am she's still gonna scream but if
my if my wife holds her
she can calm her now so and that's when
you see the superpower of women
yeah so I actually have zero sympathy
for single mothers yes in general not
your mom you know I'm sorry
but but it's like I I because the way I
think is you always have a choice as a
woman where men don't always have a
choice some men will be single forever
and 40 only 40 of men have reproduced
historically so now it's like me if
you're born with all this beauty and
value and you pick poorly isn't isn't
that your own fault what where is the in
even single mothers there's always a
simp there's always someone so to me
it's just always a choice yeah do you
disagree no you're an empathetic no
actually no no no I am empathetic but I
I will say I think what you said is a
good point I respect the commitment
level of a woman who's single or a
father who's single and they raise a
child if you're a father or a mother it
doesn't matter just one single parent
raising a child that's really really
hard I really believe in the traditional
marriage and man you know it's such a
shame that in the 36 hours I've been
here in London
I see all this we're talking about this
I see all this advertisement about what
represents London and at the airport I
see four pictures
and out of those four pictures two of
them are pictures of homosexuality but I
didn't see one picture of like
a 40 year old man Muslim Christian
doesn't matter or Jewish like me doesn't
matter just a traditional man with a
wife
and like two kids sitting at the park
I found that I find that really
offensive actually as a married man as a
father who has Faith uh I find it
offensive that we're being ignored from
society yet we make up such a big
majority of men and and most men that
are happy
or the highest degree of happiness I
think are the ones at least in my own
life that I know this is antidotal but
are married men
I love having a wife and a daughter I
couldn't imagine waking up and not
having them I hope it doesn't happen but
wouldn't you want to promote instead of
25 gay flags and I respect the gays I
really do alpha King loves the gays I
don't emphasize that but wouldn't it be
amazing if we had one advertisement in
London one advert here in London or one
advertisement in Miami just showed me a
[__] billboard with a man who's at
the park with his wife and his two sons
playing football when I was growing up I
would see stuff like that now I come to
London or you go to New York you just
see you know the gay flag the trans flag
yeah and the crazy thing is most gay
people I know don't want this [__]
pushed unless they're really extreme
there's a lot of there's a lot of based
people that that are gay and they're not
with all the like the lgbtq plus [__] my
gay my my gay uh therapist was who I
have a lot of love for he's gay and he
explained it to me that best he said
when the gay first it was about being
gay and having gay rights but then they
began pushing the trans stuff and the
trans stuff gets even darker because
what they're doing is they're trying to
show that
they're changing the definition of what
a human is
and when you start doing that 5 10 15
years from now we're going to start
having robots and then you're talking
about what businesses will do with
robots the displacement of jobs
and it really gets far far darker than
just oh that's a trend we're just
changing the definition of a human
altogether at this point
I don't know I think this is all a
depopulation agenda and I just I think
it's actually disgusting I mean I've
seen we were just talking about this
earlier like when I saw the dudes in the
woman's locker room at my school I was
like this is getting too far this is
crazy and and the crazy thing is these
people know that this isn't right they
know that men or men and women are women
but they still it's like they pretend
for what why why are you pushing this
agenda on to us I would be really
surprised if anyone in the chat is a
father
and and the father says and has a
daughter and says I would like my 13
year old daughter to go to a woman's
public bathroom and men that are trans
can go in there and they're willing to
have their daughter risk getting
graped
because I'll tell you as a father right
now I wouldn't feel comfortable with
that degeneracy
and to say oh nothing would ever happen
it does happen you're being lied to
you're being programmed you're being
indoctrinated
it's wrong in any other country you go
around the world you go to Africa you go
to Middle East you go to Asia you go to
Russia you think they're going to let a
man dress as a woman and go on the same
bathroom as your 12 year old daughter
you know how disgusting that is
and dangerous how about the safety of my
daughter it's like if they're willing to
chop their off what are they going to do
to me you're like is that that's pretty
far that's crazy it's not crazy to think
you don't want you I say this as a
father and I can't and I find it really
sad that fathers like me
42 year old fathers and married men like
me are not seen in advertisements in
Western Society like we're not normal
like we're not we're we're we're unusual
because we're not gay and trans I can
understand put 10 pictures of gays fine
but can we get at least one picture of a
traditional man no the ratio right now
is 100 gay flags maybe you see
one man married
with kids at the park in an
advertisement well and the crazy thing
is when they do advert like when they do
depict a picture perfect like family
it's always the dad's an idiot they
always like Homer Simpson a bumbling
idiot the woman just knows everything
and they that's always how even Family
Guy same thing overweight idiot and the
woman knows everything Lisa is stupid
Bard is smart they even do it with the
kids not crazy yeah it is and it it's
sort of like even the Hollywood movies
man like in the like
like you'll see Vikings and the Viking
is like an African guy like like the
it's it's like or like you know uh James
Bond will become a woman right like
we're just changing like all of these
things to
um oh my gosh what Scarlett Johansson
being in the Avengers or whatever the
hell superhero movie she played in is
offensive as a female athlete okay I can
I can deadlift roughly 300 pounds I had
Pro contracts offered I can squat like
250 275 I am strong I'm probably top one
percent of strength for a female all
right I can I can bench a plate I am a
strong woman and you're gonna put this
petite five two five three chick as the
lead in the action movie who is she who
is she gonna beat up and then she's
leading the men I'm like this is I was
offended as an athlete I would I would
have taken Riley Gaines over Scarlett
Johansson Hanson but I'm going to ask
you next do you think I'm single mothers
deserve sympathy
interesting because there's four women
here
yeah four women here and we've all said
no I I don't think so either they well I
think if the other half of the panel was
still here we would have had mixed maybe
I think um women when they're divorced
and they decide to be single mothers and
do everything on their own that's a
choice when the kids are at school I
think they should be going to the gym
and making themselves look presentable
like at an appropriate weight look after
yourself inside out and go out with your
friends make some time for yourself
Learn To Love Yourself work on yourself
but I think it's really important that
once they've
found that self-love and respect
self-respect you can go out you can meet
people and
yeah it's it's a choice to stay at home
and stay in this vicious circle of work
school run I wanna I wanna hear from
okay since we have three divorced women
oh sorry sorry sorry the lady in the red
she did say you should have five men
around you that I wholly disagree with
how can you ever move on which man would
ever accept the woman if she had four
other men that were running around
around her and if he doesn't find out
then where is the commitment already
you're already a cheap bag you've got
four men that the first man doesn't know
about you're about to commit to one you
have a choice I wholly disagree I think
it's disgusting maybe you didn't listen
me correct I told you don't sleep with
them you communicate it's still in my
eyes I wouldn't if I if I was a man and
I had I was interested in a woman and
then I found out she was even speaking
or going on a date with four other men I
would tell her to [__] off pardon my
French
have a lot of women and women stay home
and now every day I work with I have a
man now and he's with no one but me and
I know that for a fact it's called
respect you respect yourself you find
something you have a man until you're
not exclusivity until my not told you
you are my woman I will take care about
you but until this I disagree I disagree
a woman I disagree I think maybe it's a
culture thing for me I don't know but I
completely disagree if a woman can't
respect herself she will never get
respect anywhere else yeah it's
interesting I've heard this before the
roster thing like gonna I mean I think
we usually women mean to sleep with them
but you're saying don't sleep with them
you don't think that's a bit
disrespectful to the like if one guy and
you can tell me why you don't think this
but like if one guy's gonna take you
seriously and then he finds out you're
talking to people
um if I'm not you 22 years
psychotherapist and I make so many
marriage of my clients I made it I make
a magic marriage and so many children we
have in this world and I do it every day
eight hours and I know all about
relationship again for example I have
one client she's single and she really
want to find the man she go and she met
with some men in Tinder it's first man
which she saw from one year
oh hi Kim I love him she he not say man
one year and immediately
to laugh and guy plays her they go one
dinner and she won't saw him attention
he offered her cheeky chicken she is so
one man she's ready for all just to keep
him she's 42 she never was in a big
relationship many years and she goes she
never had a relationship she'd been in a
relationship but uh one year she was out
okay and she goes with him tricky cheeky
and the next day he disappeared
she called me cry Natalia please help me
he disappeared what to do I'd say why
you go with one man I told you you need
to have five because if you have other
four if you call somebody just to drink
a coffee you know to slow down how you
feel now even to drink one coffee give
you one rose you're not your soul down
in my opinion A real man doesn't want a
woman like that if that's my opinion A
real man if he exists he would not want
a woman his woman she's probably his
from day one he would not want his woman
speaking to another woman another guy
that's not a real man I that's the kind
of a man who would allow a woman to do
that because he's not serious about her
he will just F her and leave her and
drain her and rinse her and waste her
time he will not marry her he will not
give her kids he will not look after her
end of and I'm sorry it's undisputable
that for me is undisputable that's not a
real result and I know how to marry
people how many marriages few people
will marry real women will marry
themselves real women will marry
themselves it's amazing what you do no
disrespect but a real woman and a real
man they don't really need I think
anyone's intervention except maybe just
an intro at a party or something I
wholly disagree with you I'm so sorry
but I disagree yeah people have
different opinions I know because all my
marriage when a work I work from result
and when clients to me they say I want
to marry and my work to help my client
Merit and I know how many marriage I did
in my life and I had a man who is not
possible to Mary and from my strategy we
married them and after they invite me to
be the goddess mother from children I
know how do you think the the the tender
thing right and imagine like dating apps
aren't the best place for women no no no
but you need to know how to do it so
yeah so this is I'm just gonna ask you
so based on your your practice I'd
imagine like women swipe too high on
dating apps because we only swipe right
five percent of the time we find eighty
percent of men ugly I'm sure you know
the numbers so it's like if you go on a
date with a guy from a dating app he's
probably dating you must to be honest
yeah and you honestly I am now in choice
we can drink a coffee we can speak but
you need to do something to show them is
it you want to be with me because today
men go with women in park even don't
give one rose
today men very often go to meeting
because I work every day with dating in
UK and Men even go with not clean
clothes not airing clothes and Men come
and say do you want to go to myself
don't you think that's like the question
this is laughable a real man you don't
have to say can you give me a rose can
you give show me show me show me oh I I
think this is your mind I will give you
a rose I don't I don't know if a real
man like
fantasy
I don't even want to talk about real
verses not but my my thing is I I think
it speaks to the quality of the women
though and so it's like obviously if the
women are lower quality than ever before
the men are going to treat them
traditionally because it's like even if
the 42 year old why would she get a
traditional outcome
very often with very successful women in
career yeah and but they have very low
level level of self-confidence as a
women because for example her mother
always told her you're very ugly pure
father very toxic narcissistic and every
day I work with this she can be
Financial director and big company a
lawyer but when men stayed to her she
don't know how to be a woman but the man
you know men don't care about your
career though exactly allows you to be
beautiful right and to be sexy and to be
attractive he doesn't care how many
education you have and if you have PhD
right but I I really think I don't find
that women are maybe it's in different
countries I don't know I I find that
they're they're they have too high of
Standards not too low
yes because because it's like they find
80 percent of men is ugly so that means
that means they don't need to be
beautiful mine need to be honest my need
to be strong I need to have a
realization in his mission right social
successful and to be a man you don't
need to be beautiful woman wants to be
beautiful yeah and I and I agree with
you but I'm saying in the west that's
that's how we select typically it's more
based on looks and because we are women
sometimes stupid and we are women
sometimes go and to choose his good
looking can I say wait wait wait he has
his house he can take care about you he
is responsible he's honest
and I spoke also with man he said me if
I feel that woman uh catch up on me I
don't think to think of her I want other
women and if I feel that I have
competitors yeah it's activated me
because I know that she has another four
who drink coffee play tennis and I say
hmm I must be better than others and
then I want to run for her then I want
to do something for her competitors
activate normal men if men of uh not a
female man of course he will go far away
but man he feel that he can lost and he
really likened you are very right need
to be high level of woman of course you
are smart you just drink a coffee again
I say you don't sleep with them you are
in Choice your go to market you say I am
a single woman I'd have just take it
five that's a lot though a minimum five
can be ten
like I almost think that's like
disrespectful to a guy what she's trying
to say there which I think I'm getting
her point and I got your point as well
yeah is I think what she's trying to say
um is uh no not to have a backup it's
more to do with the development for a
woman you're not attached to that one
person that you jump to it and put all
like it's don't you think that's bad
don't you don't you think don't you
think that's what's like beautiful about
being a woman though is you get attached
if there's no attachment you're gonna
leave that guy with a click of a finger
there's no respect no no no but what
what do you mention is the first guy
left her after sleeping with her
instantly so what she's trying to say
why did she sleep with him so quick
exactly because she's not his men in the
first man he give your attention when I
wanna I wanna hear it I'm sorry
when she talks to four or five men but
from a respectful place is she's not
being like flirty or giving herself away
she's developing yeah she's developing
this quality to bring boundaries for
herself
I'm just thinking if you're talking to
five men you still have a favorite
friends you have brothers you have you
have friends and brothers and dads and
stepdads and whatever to do that kind of
stuff random men on a dating app passed
one and it's serious you're talking you
it's wrong it's disturbing is it what
are the guys think of this yeah real
real quick I say this to the lady behind
me is it fair to generalize all men like
this for example if I were to say all
women who are allowed and obnoxious like
you usually wind up having a divorce
would that be fair
I think people get divorced for
different reasons different reasons
and generalizing someone anyone no it's
not fair
no it's not fair but did I generally be
honest no it's not fair but I also think
a woman has the power to uh develop
herself look it's like how do you know
to swim until you go in the water so you
figure out your boundaries your respect
you're not sleeping with that person but
you're also then getting awareness of
okay there is different variety of mans
they have different values they have
different standards and whoever from
those five will pick me and then I under
I understand like I under I understand
where she's coming from like so I'm not
even discrediting it I'm just but I'm
just wait wait so I'm I'm just thinking
like that just sounds like more for
traditional women which don't really
exist anymore like that sounds like more
traditional chording you know you know
what I mean
uh Japan feminists and not feminists a
lot of women prefer to survive alone and
it's very difficult in this world yeah
for example I am not from this I believe
that men need to be this woman and I
cannot without men I I drive a car but I
prefer my partner always to drive a car
I think we're going to drive yeah
but you're honest I guess you say my
name I'm single I like to meet with
people I like to communicate you play
tennis you go to drink coffee you don't
social place because you need to
understand what you want when you're
divorced when you're single you don't
know if you don't communicate with
different type of people different age
different culture how you can know then
if you take the first and you will do
the same mistake because you're very
wants attention
what do you think
the five men speak to at the same time
but don't sleep with them do you think
that's like do you think that's
disrespectful if you were like courting
a girl and she was talking to five other
guys at the same time you know it's
interesting I struggled with jealousy uh
almost my entire life and I finally
realized and this is especially if
you're a man who struggles with jealousy
the way I did I you know I'm
Mediterranean Middle Eastern man so
maybe that's a genetic thing I struggled
with jealousy really bad I was pretty
controlling and uh it wasn't until I
actually met my wife that I realized I
couldn't stop a woman from lying and
cheating to me and I've been cheated on
and uh and that's painful as [__]
so I realized if you can't control a
woman just relax and be confident and if
she [__] around on you that's her loss
now one more thing I want to say I trust
my wife I also think that you can stop
that problem by just meeting a woman who
has those values I'd never have to worry
about my I don't even care about going
through my wife's phone but if I wanted
to I could exactly yeah
if I wanted to go through my wife's
phone I could in fact my wife I have the
opposite problem my wife likes to go
through my phone and I get really hurt
by that because I feel like why don't
you trust me I don't go through your
phone why would you go through my phone
now she doesn't do it as much
but you know I had to I had to you don't
want to live a life where you're [__]
going crazy wondering is your woman
getting [__] by you know some big guy
no but I'm just asking like if you found
out a girl was doing what she yeah but
to answer your question I wouldn't deal
with it I'd believer there's no [__]
way I would be with a woman and she and
I'm seeing she's talking to Johnny at
2AM he he on text message I'd leave her
I don't give a [__] because I know my
worth
you know I think are there Mendo that
would
um go along with what she's saying yeah
but what she's saying is advocating on
women's behalf and I get that I can
respect that but if you're a man you're
making money you're taking care of your
mind your body you know you got a good
faith with the Lord
have some self-respect have some [__]
self-respect that if a woman behaves
like that you dropped a hoe
straight up so I what my question here
is like when you're at the very start of
the relationship where you just started
saying hello to four or five different
people and then somebody come forward
and then said they are interested in you
then you drop all the other men and then
you're focusing on that person when
you're in relationship you stay
monogamic it's not discussed but before
to be in monogamic relationship partner
need to show you I want to be with you I
am have interest with you not like
cheeky chicken he disappeared and he cry
alone especially the point you raised
about a woman chooses like you know it's
her decision she made and she attracted
somebody now the very first guy that
came into your life and if you don't
give yourself that choice of actually
for that you have to go out and look out
and see which one it is but he's
absolutely right if I am giving somebody
this idea of I'm in relationship with
you and I'm talking to five other people
I don't think he's talking
he's talking about even early on like I
I just think if you're talking like this
is just my opinion but I think if you're
talking to Five Guys like I don't know
how you keep track to be honest
it just seems to be like taking
attention from men to feel your ego you
know I have a lot of single moms which
I'm married and I help them and I say go
out I'm tired you want to be married or
you don't want I have one single man she
come to me 42. she was very suffering
with her son and I told her go up and
speak with minimum five men she go out
go drink coffee with five from this five
she likes four she go from dinner uh
with four after from four she choose two
with them she go more close and from
this too she choose one now already
she's married 10 years and Guy amazing
very careful out here they know that
she's single she's looking and uh very
very big successful man man also respect
one woman honest and yes of course you
have a choice and you need to do
something to be with you you know what
you know a clear definition of Miss
Andrea I'll give you a great example of
of of Miss Andrea in in pop culture in
America there was a tick tocker I'm not
going to say her name so the video
doesn't get pulled down she made a video
talking about how she saved a lot of
money
going on a date like six nights a week
basically she would go with a different
guy every night and she would save the
money and she was giving this as a
personal finance hack now this is not
even comedy this is Finance on Tick Tock
that did most degenerate app aside from
Snapchat
and that gets promoted she has millions
of followers she's getting corporate
sponsorship deals but if you see a video
of like let's say snico Tristan Tate
myself other guys that's talking about
you should have some self-respect for
yourself that gets pulled down for hate
speech yeah
yeah
it's crazy
I just think a lot of times like men
like I don't know I would just be really
frustrated if I like if I was a dude and
I'm paying for this girl's dinner she's
talking to five other dudes or ten you
know I mean this this influencer was
literally celebrated honest though you
know you don't go let me think and say
hello I have five friends list to speak
you say I'm single and I'm looking and
don't give discuss explain and man do
the same man he's looking he do the same
I make a session with men's men do the
same and she looking closer he go out
and humid he don't take it was the first
woman which I see in Tinder and to marry
her yeah but the difference with men is
that while men are doing that they are
paying for it through their pockets
women are doing that free of charge in
Japan no it doesn't depend most of the
time women are not going on dates paying
for the dates most of the time thanks
packs you can go play tennis you can go
to park I mean literally this girl you
anyone can fact check me anyone can hold
on anyone can fact check me you can go
on New York Post and look at the article
they wrote about this influencer not a
comedy influencer a finance influencer
saying how she's encouraging women
basically to go on dates with men
no chance of getting some [__] you're
not gonna [__] the guy you're gonna go
on a diet you're gonna mislead the guy
get a free dinner go home and do that
six nights a week to save money and
she's being celebrated in the media and
on Tick Tock and she's verified but then
if I say something about men having some
self-respect for themselves
or other creators like sneako Tristan
Tate they're all banned all of us got
banned but she's promoted
make that make sense yeah it's super
wrong no that that is abuse of uh you
know
it's very common it's very common at the
same time
literally the same time I can't remember
what percent it was over half of women
have admitted to going on a bandwidth or
going on a date with a guy for dinner
it's super common I'm not a feminist but
I am a human rights activist it's not
about equal like women being any you
know like but there is it's a 21st
century and there's equality what made
you laugh sir
and the reality is a lot of women would
accept dates for men maybe pay 50 50 and
then you know it a lot of women would
accept dates from men that they already
know they are not going to want to
further after that they're probably not
going to want to see them again so yeah
that's wrong that's wrong if you know
you're clear and you're doing this
that's uh I totally agree what you have
to make is that that is very common it
is very very common I know it sounds
weird but it's reality it is common it
may be 10 years ago it wasn't that
common but right now today
it's like you said it's celebrated on
Tick Tock you can just open Tick Tock
you see it everything you know what's
crazy though she can come on here or
other platforms and say this nobody's
gonna bat an eye but if guys say to spin
plates
everybody freaks out if they say to
sleep with multiple women talk to as
many women as possible everybody freaks
out
then they and they even if the women
agree to it like I mean how often will I
just reacted to a video of like this
Christian person basically like um I
forgot her name but she was like
shaming you know Justin Waller because
Jay Waller was saying like basically the
not he does the non-monogamy stuff or he
talks about it I don't know but it's
like um it's just interesting how it's
like women can talk about spinning
plates and it's fine but if men talk
about spinning plates it's not
yeah it has become a touchy subject I
suppose um uh where it started from is
to protect women but it has gone the
other side you know what the question is
like what about all the men giving her
attention so like let's protect the men
you know I know like in Indian culture
there is there is now a thing because in
India women get a lot of power comparing
to men so it's like woman has right men
has to chase women like this is like a
done thing like they're around their
beauty Etc and I've met men who was
really struggled with that concept and
they says
um you know if you divorce them you have
to give them money they are they are in
power they are in high five jobs and
they run the shows and they really they
really struggle men really struggle and
have huge fear around it so that part in
this world exists and I agree with you
it needs to be spoken about like you
know it needs to be given equal
importance to what women suffer
Sometimes women abuse not sometimes
sounds like it a lot of the time they do
I'm on the other side of it though
having six brothers I always like it it
burns my um blood when people say oh
it's the man who's at fault kind of
thing and I'm like no my point is the
women have all the choice
like because we are born with value we
have all the choice the men do not have
Choice oh I mean some men do but most
men don't I feel and so that's why like
with women it's like I kind of don't
have any sympathy for your lot in life
myself as well every everything
everything you do in life I just think
is your own fault and I think that a lot
of times women
aren't aware of how hard dating is for
men exactly I I think where I give uh
that see the difference is women are
very vocal emotional they get to share
we love to be the victim we love to
[__] and moan about how hard dating is
men don't really
I mean even in this whole thing like she
they're yelling at me for kicking them
out when how many times did I warn them
yeah how many times did I warn them I
warned them so many times and now victim
it's like craziness
um I'm gonna Read Super chats one more
time though and yeah I was about to say
we're about to end the show and so what
we can do is we'll do final thoughts
um okay guys make sure you like the
video um guys send super chats for a
kickout cam Glenn Lawrence all the girl
in red is talking about is spinning
plates if a guy that has five to ten
plates he doesn't care what one plate is
doing who cares what he's crying about
uh 90 free till pie after 30 stop asking
why it is what it is Dr David Baker um
single women are feel free to feel free
to play the field but having a roster of
five to ten menu friend zoned and blue
balled but they take you on dates and do
uh favors that sounds vaguely
exploitational Glenn Lawrence she is
just saying it's okay for women to spin
plates there's nothing wrong with that
guy should be doing that to Adam Sutton
um
okay Adam Adam Sutton says if you're not
a virgin and withhold sex that's 304
Behavior you're leveraging sex to
extract resources Dr David Baker
Undisputed line of the day oh so the
over over the divorce overweight baby
mama is talking to me about marriage
Savage and totally justify yes you want
to talk about I was single I'm just
talking about her relationship status is
nine to Frito pie um dads have to be
dads and moms when they get home from
work in the modern world because women
are so strong God bless fathers Glenn
Lawrence I love breasts too I have zero
sympathy for single mothers Carlos ax
kick him 932 Prime Iron is better
because he's a guy Gloria Glenn Lawrence
uh okay I think that's all of them so
you want to do final thoughts yeah yeah
so go ahead
um
what it was what would be a just
anything yeah any thoughts you have
about the show you know um you can also
plug your social media now so oh yeah so
uh I'm actually on uh I I'm always
losing stuff so I'm on Instagram YouTube
and you can just go on uh Tick Tock or
Twitter put my name Nemo yamini or Alpha
King Nema and you'll see me
um thank you Pearl for having me this
was a great experience yeah thanks for
coming thank you very much
thank you a lot I wish you to have a
Love Goes My need your admiration they
might need love be yourself be open try
until not you find your love believe in
love my book Natalia a navigation of
success it's one of the first book about
how women to be entrepreneuring how to
make female business and how to be happy
in your life welcome and thank you
Natalia kobilkina
uh for me um I learned a lot from this
experience this was very new for me in
terms of how it was set up and
everything and yeah it takes literally
it takes courage it takes to put
something like this together and talk
about these things openly so well done
for doing that thank you guys for being
respectful thank you thank you go ahead
Pearl I just want to say thank you so
much for speaking to everybody hello
there you go Pearl thank you so much for
having me on your show and in your place
amazing I am I really enjoyed meeting
lots of new people
um and I think the biggest lesson for
today is everyone has opinions you've
got to learn to respect them you also
have opinions others well you know it's
just just respect other people's
opinions and just be yourself
um if anybody wants to connect I'm lady
nura Jahan on Instagram and I'd like to
say to everybody that says I only bring
on crazy delusional women on the show I
bring a nice respectful women all the
time all the time I didn't know that I
look at all the time they just don't
always you know go viral because you're
not acting crazy and you really can't
screen for crazy you know I want to see
you guys fill a studio six days a week
and tell me how picky you can be about
guests before before you do that
um okay Jacob says here you go Pearl
twenty dollars for the kick out cam guys
please like the video on your way out um
I think last show we got a thousand
likes so I'd really like to get a
thousand five hundred so if you could
hit the like button on the way out on
the way out subscribe to the channel
we'll talk to you next time
foreign